Herzlich Willkommen zu Alternativlos, die Folge numero? 49. 49. Ja, wir hatten ja so gewisse Verzögerungen im Betriebsablauf bei der Produktion der neuen Sendung. Möchten uns natürlich dafür entschuldigen, dass wir etwas länger gebraucht haben als manchmal so üblich. Wir hatten zwischendurch schon eine Sendung mit Gast irgendwie geplant und vereinbart, da kam dann allerdings leider Corona dazwischen. Insofern hat es etwas länger gedauert und wie immer geloben wir Besserung und wissen aber nicht, ob wir es einhalten können. Also schauen wir mal.
Also eigentlich ist es natürlich der Franks Schuld, aber ich muss sagen, ich bin auch furchtbar müde. Weiß nicht, ob ihr auch alle so müde seid. Ich bin so müde vor diesem ganzen Covid-Scheiß. Ich könnte jetzt echt mal so ein Jahr ohne Covid brauchen.
Ja, so ein Jahr ohne Corona wäre schon ganz gut.
Aber es sieht ja nicht so aus. Ja, als Thema der Sendung hatten wir uns gedacht, wir machen mal die Rolle des Staates in der Gesellschaft, weil wir glauben, das ist eigentlich der Dreh- und Angelpunkt, der entscheidet, wie man den Rest der Fragestellungen angeht. Und beim Übernachtdenken ist uns aufgefallen, dass wir noch einen zweiten Teil brauchen. Der wird wahrscheinlich ein bisschen umfangreicher. Ja, der Staat in der Gesellschaft, da gibt es so ein Spektrum. Auf der einen Seite gibt es den libertären Ansatz, so Ronald Reagan und Thatcher von ihren Idealen her. Wir brauchen weniger Staat. Der Staat soll so wenig wie möglich tun, aber so viel wie nötig ist der Spruch. Das sehen natürlich eigentlich alle so, aber es gibt halt unterschiedliche Meinungen darüber, was nötig ist.
Ja, und auf der anderen Seite gibt es den Ansatz zu sagen, der Staat ist der Einzige, der in einer kapitalistischen Gesellschaft einigermaßen ehrlich handeln kann oder im Interesse der Allgemeinheit handeln kann, weil in dem Augenblick, wo ein Profitmotiv dabei ist, wird dieses Profitmotiv irgendwie alles andere überlagern. Das sind so die beiden Ecken des Spektrums. Und die Frage ist halt, irgendwie welches Ziel verfolgt man da gerade? Und momentan haben wir durchaus auch zum Teil bedingt durch irgendwie diese Corona-Geschichte den Zustand, dass mehr Leute glauben, wir brauchen mehr Staat und mehr staatliches Handeln. Sei gut, so als bevor Corona war die Annahme immer, das wäre prima notwendig, um die Klimakrise in den Griff zu bekommen. Inzwischen erstreckt sich das dann eben auch noch in weitere Bereiche des Lebens. Und ich hab da ehrlich gesagt so ein bisschen so ein Problem damit, weil wenn ich mir so das Handeln des Staates in dieser Corona-Geschichte angucke, sehe ich da halt einen weitgehend inkompetenten Akteur, der weder mit den Ressourcen sinnvoll umgeht, noch irgendwie sinnvolle Ergebnisse erzielt. Und jetzt noch mehr davon zu wollen, ist finde ich irgendwie so ein bisschen schwierig. Also da habe ich irgendwie nicht so ein gutes Gefühl dabei.
Ich finde, man muss noch ein bisschen vorsichtig sein, weil es gibt da auch viel Unehrlichkeit und Subjektivität. Also zum Beispiel, ich als Bürger habe einen Anreiz dafür zu finden, der Staat sollte sich schon kümmern, weil dann ist es nicht meine Schuld, wenn Sachen vor die Wand fahren. Ja, dass ich sage, die Verantwortung dafür, dass die Dinge vernünftig laufen, liegen beim Staat. Wenn ich irgendwo, sagen wir mal, über einen Bürgersteig laufe im Winter und der ist nicht gekehrt, dann ist das eigentlich Schuld des Staates, denn der hätte das sozusagen entforsten müssen, dass der Typ da sauber macht oder selber sauber machen müssen. Also selbst wenn sozusagen ein Individuum Mist macht, würde ich immer noch sagen, der Staat ist schuld als Bürger, weil dann bin ich auch weniger schuld. Und das ist halt eine Grundlage dessen, wie Leute gern die Welt sehen, dass jemand anderes schuld ist. Ja, und auf der anderen Seite haben wir den Staat, der möchte gern das Image projizieren, dass er zuständig ist und handelt. Aber historisch gesehen, und eigentlich ist er eher ein Beobachter. Also der versucht zwar Anreize zu setzen, aber die sind meistens entweder impotent oder absichtlich so kastriert, dass die Fördertöpfe nicht abgegriffen werden. Da hab ich neulich mal so eine Liste gemacht. Also wenn ihr einfach mal zu Google geht und nach Fördertopf und nicht ausgeschöpft sucht, da findet ihr eine lange Liste. Inklusive Fördertopf für Pflegepersonal. Ganz aktuell. Also der Staat möchte immer so gesehen werden, als würde er hier Verantwortung übernehmen und Dinge regeln. Aber eigentlich möchte der Staat, dass sich die Sachen von selber regeln. Und oft tun sie das auch. Also wenn man zum Beispiel einfach nicht reagiert, bis es nicht länger geht, das war immer die Politik der Frau Merkel, dann wartet man mit dem Brücken und Autobahn restaurieren, bis die ersten Leute einen Unfall haben. Und dann gibt es auch kein Problem mehr bei den Budgetverhandlungen, dass man da jetzt Geld ausgeben muss. Das ist also bisher die Strategie gewesen. Und jetzt in Covid kommt das halt schneller, der Moment, wo man dann mal was hätte tun müssen. Aber das ist ein Muster, was man häufig beobachten kann. Auch zum Beispiel bei der Hochwasserkatastrophe. Da war das auch so, dass danach plötzlich viel mehr Geld da war, als man sinnvoll investieren konnte. Und dass die Geldschwemme sozusagen noch die Leute belohnt hat, die ihre Häuser im Hochwassergebiet gebaut haben. Ja, weil einfach das nicht vorher sinnvoll ausgegeben wurde, sondern danach mit der Gießkanne, damit man sagen konnte, guck mal, der Staat hilft.
Naja, der neoliberale Ansatz wäre jetzt halt zu sagen, eigentlich sollte der Staat den Leuten nicht helfen, damit sie da nicht noch mal hinbauen. Aber das bringt natürlich niemand übers Herz.
Ja, vor allem sieht man sich auch selber natürlich in der Situation, dass man irgendwas übersehen hat. Also zum Beispiel wohne ich ja jetzt hier nicht in dem Haus, weil mir das Haus so gut gefällt, sondern da war eine Wohnung frei, als ich eine gebraucht habe. Und natürlich ist nicht alles toll. Aber wenn jetzt hier zum Beispiel rauskommt, dass hier, was weiß ich, Schwermetalle im Boden sind, da würde ich ungern nicht die Verantwortung für übernehmen, weil ich bin hier bloß in eine Wohnung eingezogen in dem Haus. So das heißt, der Instinkt des Bürgers ist immer zu sagen, der Staat hat zu wenig gemacht. Aber es ist auf der anderen Seite auch Instinkt, dem Staat nicht die Mittel geben zu wollen, dass er die Sachen wirklich tun kann.
Na gut, aber lass uns mal ganz kurz bei diesem Wohnungsbeispiel bleiben, weil das finde ich ganz interessant. Weil eine der Aufgaben des Staates außer Anreißes setzen, ist ja Standardsetzen. Also wenn man jetzt so ein bisschen zurückguckt in den, also ich vereinfache hier sehr stark und die Historiker mögen mir verzeihen, aber wenn man so ein bisschen zurückguckt in den Ursprung des Staatswesens, dann gab es ja so zwei Funktionen. Die eine war Sicherheit bereitzustellen, also gegen externe Angreifer oder interne Kriminelle. Und zum anderen Standard zu setzen, also sowas wie Maße und Gewichte regeln auf einem Markt. Also wenn man sich die erfolgreichen Hansestädte zum Beispiel anguckt, die haben sich ja, haben ja im Wesentlichen halt diese beiden Funktionen übernommen. Nämlich halt zu sagen, wer kann welches Gewerbe in dieser Stadt ausüben. Sie haben Sicherheit für die Handelswege bereitgestellt und sie haben Maße und Gewichte reguliert, damit man halt da nicht irgendwie zu sehr beschissen wird. Und eigentlich wäre jetzt in dem Beispiel deiner Wohnung wäre ja die Aufgabe des Staates zu sagen, okay, du hast halt irgendwie von dem, von dem du die Wohnung mietest oder kaufst, die Zusicherung, dass irgendwie da irgendwie keine Schwermetalle sind. Und falls es da doch Schwermetalle gibt, dann müsste die Justiz als Teil des Staates dir dann halt irgendwie Gerechtigkeit verschaffen, weil dir halt unaufensichtlich mangelhaft das Produkt verkauft wurde. Das wäre ja der sinnvolle Weg, zu sagen, der Staat beschränkt sich in diesem Fall halt dafür zu sorgen, dass dir halt nicht ein Scheiß verkauft wird, oder falls doch, du halt irgendwie ein Mittel hast, irgendwie einen Ausgleich zu bekommen. Aber jetzt, dass der Staat jetzt dir sozusagen Schadenersatz leistet dafür, dass irgendjemand anders dich übers Ohr gehauen hat, auch möglicherweise unwissend nicht übers Ohr gehauen hat, weil er damals nicht wusste, dass da Schwermetalle in deiner Wand sind, ist halt eigentlich schon, geht halt schon darüber hinaus irgendwie.
Ja, auf der anderen Seite haben wir auch so Sachen, wie dass neue Gesetze gar nicht machbar wären, wenn man da eine Bestrafung von existierenden Installationen hat, sodass es häufig so eine sogenannte Großvaterklausel gibt, mit der bestehende oder Bestandsschutz nennt sich das auf Deutsch, mit dem man halt bestehende vor dem Eintritt des Gesetzes angeschaffte Sachen ausnimmt. Was dann halt zu so Sachen führt, wie es gab diesen Fall der Guinness-Brauerei, die aus historischen Gründen auf einem Pachtvertrag von ich weiß nicht 100 Jahren oder so saß und so etwas wie ein Ginni zahlt, was halt irgendwie so 350 sind. Also eher symbolisch die Miete, die die da zahlen, aber ist halt Bestandsschutz. Der alte Vertrag, der wird jetzt nicht irgendwie ungesetzlich plötzlich, weil die Miete nicht mehr zeitgemäß ist.
Na gut, ich meine, das ist ja dann vertragsfreiheit, wenn da keine Anpassung vorgenommen wurde.
Ja, natürlich, aber es gibt halt auch andere Sachen, wie zum Beispiel Oldtimer sind ausgenommen von Umweltschutzvorschriften, die normale Autos erfüllen müssen. Also du musst in deinen 100 Jahre alten Oldtimer musst du keinen Katalysator einbauen.
Es gibt ja noch diese Funktion des aufrechtehaltens des sozialen Friedens. Die Diskussion haben wir jetzt ja gerade in diesem gesamten Bereich, also insbesondere in Berlin, bei dem gesamten Bereich Wohnungen, wo der, was die Leute inzwischen an Miete aufrufen oder was sie an Kaufpreisen aufrufen, überhaupt nichts mehr mit irgendwelchen rationalen Nutzwerten zu tun hat, sondern nur noch halt irgendwie mit Spekulationen. Dann könnte man sich natürlich irgendwie auf den Punkt stellen, das ist durchaus argumentierbar, dass eben auch eine Rolle des Staates sein sollte, Spekulationen mit Waren und Gütern und Dienstleistungen auszubremsen, die man halt tatsächlich zum Leben und Überleben braucht. Und daraus resultiert dann in Berlin halt diese ganze Enteignungsgeschichte, also was ja eigentlich im Fakt nur ein Abkauf, ein zwangsweise Abkauf ist.
Eine Vergesellschaftung ist keine Enteignung. Achtung, da gibt es so viele Dios.
Genau. So, ich meine, Enteignung ist, wenn dir irgendwie dein Haus zwangsverkauft wird, weil es irgendwie einem Tagebau-Bagger im Weg steht. Aber gut, darüber wollen wir heute nicht diskutieren. Aber trotzdem so diese Frage, welches Spektrum an Aufgaben sollte der Staat wahrnehmen und ist der Staat dazu qualifiziert in der Lage? Ich glaube, diese Dinge muss man immer zusammen betrachten. Und wenn ich mir jetzt so angucke, also ich lebe nur halt in Berlin so. Und der Staat hier ist also, ich sag mal so, ich hab das Gefühl, das Einzige, was...
Hat nicht auf ganze Linie überzeugt in den letzten Jahren, dass er so vorsichtig formuliert.
Um es mal präzise zu machen, so das Einzige, was ich glaube, dass in dieser Stadt ein Bürokratie noch funktioniert, ist die Fendungsabteilung des Finanzamts. Und so, also der Versuch, irgendwie neue Personaldokumente zu beantragen oder irgendwie sein Fahrzeug umzumelden oder ähnliches zu tun, führt halt irgendwie regelmäßig zu dem Gefühl, dass da einfach niemand mehr zu Hause ist. Ja, also das hat irgendwie einfach nicht nichts mehr in irgendeiner Art und Weise sinnvoll vorhersagbar funktioniert.
Und die letzte Wahl, das war ja auch so ein Ding.
Genau, die letzte Wahl. Aber ich meine, also was ich halt krass finde, ist, dass die, also sagen wir, mein Fahrzeug anzumelden oder umzumelden oder ein Personaldokument zu besitzen, sind beides Funktionen, die mir der Staat ja aufzwingt.
Ich weiß genau, was du meinst. Ich war in derselben Lage. Ich habe hier jahrelang irgendwie Webseiten gesniped, damit ich einen Termin gekriegt habe und der war dann in irgendeinem fucking Außenbezirk. Also ja, das ist in Berlin das failed state. Und zwar auf jeder Ebene. Also wir haben auch, nicht nur in Berlin, also wir haben auch in anderen Bundesländern, hoffentlich den Effekt, dass eine Straße kaputt ist. Und dann reparieren sie das nicht, sondern stellen irgendwie Geschwindigkeitsbegrenzungsschild ran. Ja, weil das kostet weniger. Und also diese Art von, dass der Staat einfach seine Zuständigkeiten nicht wahrnimmt. Das ist eine häufige Beobachtung, nicht nur in Berlin.
Genau, das ist halt so ein Ding, wo man so sagt, okay, wenn der Staat halt die Aufgaben wahrnehmen soll, die halt mit so privatwirtschaftlichen Mitteln nicht oder nicht sinnvoll oder gerecht oder adäquat erledigbar sind, dann stellt sich ja die Frage, woher kommt eigentlich diese Inkompetenz und Unfähigkeit? Und so die neoliberale These ist ja, dass er halt irgendwie überladen ist, also dass er halt einfach viel zu viele Aufgaben wahrnimmt und deswegen halt einfach überfordert ist mit dem Ganzen. Und an einigen Stellen kann man dieses Argument durchaus bringen. Also es gibt halt irgendwie eine Menge Sachen, wo man sich sagen würde, okay, das wäre jetzt möglicherweise nicht so notwendig oder vielleicht auch nicht mehr notwendig, dass der Staat sich da einbringt. An anderen Stellen denkt man sich dann so wieder, naja, also warum, also nehmen wir zum Beispiel halt mal so irgendwie Zockerspekulation, also wo der Staat quasi daneben steht und zuguckt. Also da gibt es dann zwar so eine BaFin, die ab und zu mal irgendwie kleine Fische irgendwie sich anguckt und sich häuscht.
Das ist die Bankregulierungsbehörde, sollten wir vielleicht erklären, falls ich mich weiß.
Genau, ja. Also die Behörde, die, die, was ist Bundesfinanzaufsicht? Ja. Und aber deren primäres Interesse ist halt eigentlich ja die Besteuerungsgrundlage sicher zu stellen, nämlich dafür sicher zu sorgen, dass der Staat halt von aller wirtschaftlicher Aktivität irgendwie seinen Zehnten bekommt, beziehungsweise seinen Fünfzigsten oder was auch immer, die Hälfte, und die nicht irgendwie den tatsächlichen Anleger Schutz sicherzustellen. Das steht da zwar immer irgendwie in allen Prospekten drinnen, aber davon ist nur so mittelfil mitzubekommen. So und die diese Frage halt so, also wenn man jetzt als Aufgabe des Staates sieht, dass das, dass der Markt halt wohl reguliert ist, also im Sinne von sinnvoll ökonomische Aktivität stattfinden kann, ohne dass die Chance, dass du irgendwie übers Ohr gehauen wirst, irgendwie zu groß wird, also so dass es halt irgendwie nicht mehr funktioniert, was ja quasi auch der Grund war, wieso dann halt um die Maße und Gewichte stabilisiert wurden und so was wie das Eichwesen gibt und so was. Das sind ja alles durchaus sinnvolle Funktionen des Staates. Also dass halt auf dein Bierglas irgendwie so ein 0,5 Liter Strich wirklich bei 0,5 Liter ist und du gucken kannst, ob dein Bierglas irgendwie hinreichend gefüllt wurde, ist ja mal eine historisch gewachsene staatliche Aufgabe, die tatsächlich auch wirklich sehr sinnvoll ist. Aber an anderen Stellen fragt man sich dann halt so die Komplexität von Regeln. Also gerade wenn man sich jetzt so Steuerregeln anguckt, der ist halt in einer Art und Weise komplex geworden, dass es ohne professionelle Höfe nicht mehr möglich ist, diese Regeln tatsächlich einzuhalten. Also in dem Augenblick, wo es um den Staat und Geld geht, brauchst du eigentlich professionelle Höfe, sonst bist du halt einfach verloren.
Wobei zum Teil ist das auch Sampling bei uns. Also das liegt daran, dass das halt, das kriegen wir halt alle ständig mit, aber es gibt andere Bereiche, wo der Staat noch viel mehr überfordert ist, zum Beispiel Baurecht. Ja, wenn du auf deinem Grundstück sagen wir mal, irgendwie ein Gartenhaus bauen willst oder eine Garage oder sowas, oder du willst noch ein Stockwerk draufziehen, oder du hast irgendwie einen Bauernhof gekauft und möchtest ja jetzt gerne deinen Betrieb drin gründen, da bist du mit Jahren des Ämtergehens und wartest auf irgendwelche Gutachter und irgendwie Einsprüche von irgendwelchen Behörden, beschäftigt. Also es ist auch eins der Hauptversprechen der neuen Ampelkoalition, dass sie gesagt haben, das sei der Hauptgrund, warum der Breitbandausbau auf dem Land nicht zurechtkommt, ist, weil es zu viele kommunale Einsprüche gegen Baumaßnahmen gibt. Und da ist zum Teil sicher vorgeschoben, aber da ist was wahres dran. Und da kann man ja durchaus die Frage stellen, wieso darf eigentlich der Staat mir erzählen, ob ich hier eine Garage bauen kann auf meinem Grundstück oder nicht. Da könnte man ja auch mal darüber diskutieren, ob das überhaupt sinnvoll ist.
Naja, das sind halt in der Regel dann halt so, also häufig sind es halt so diese Zonierungsregelungen, dass man sagt, das ist jetzt hier Außenbereich oder Innenbereich oder Gewerbegebiet oder Gemischtgebiet oder so. Und da geht es ja darum, dass mit solchen kleinteiligen Regeln versucht wird, ein übergeordnetes Interesse, was halt in der Regel dann durch Beschluss von dem, was auch immer Gemeindeparlament oder so festgelegt wurde, darüber, wie sich die Landschaft und die Nutzung dieser Landschaft in dieser Gegend entwickeln wollen, durchzusetzen. Sodass man sagt, wir wollen nicht, dass hier alles zersiedelt wird. Wir wollen nicht, dass die Häuser hier vierstöckig sind, weil irgendwie hier soll es möglichst nicht entkosy und dörflich sein.
Hier ist ein Flughafen in der Nähe. Ja, oder sowas.
Was auch immer. Also quasi Regeln, die mal gemacht wurden im Sinne des Erhalts der Lebensumgebung, so wie sie gerade ist oder so. Das sind die allerhäufigsten Sachen. Oder zum Beispiel, du darfst zwar deinen Bauernhof sanieren, aber du darfst darin keine Vermietung zu touristischen Zwecken durchführen. Und sie so, hä, wieso darf ich das nicht? Naja, der Grund ist halt, dass diese Regel dann durchgesetzt wurde von den Leuten, die da schon touristische Vermietungen haben und nicht noch mehr Konkurrenz in der Gegend wollen. Ja, das ist nicht so selten tatsächlich so, also gerade in Brandenburg, dass also dann quasi dann dieser Bestandsschutz für ein existierendes Gewerbe über deine handlungsfreiheit als Eigentümer gestellt wird. Und die, da kann man sich dann halt auch fragen, ist das jetzt eigentlich gerechtfertigt so? Oder ist der der positive Effekt davon, ist der größer als irgendwie der negative Aspekt? Letzten Endes landet man da genau in dieser Diskussion, die wir jetzt ja gerade bei Corona haben, mit dieser Impfpflicht Debatte, wo sich dann halt die Frage stellt, so wie viel Einschränkung von persönlicher Freiheit soll denn so ein Staat machen dürfen und aus welchen Gründen? Und wie haben wir uns eigentlich darauf geeinigt, dass diese Gründe jetzt eigentlich okay sind? So und ich glaube, das, was wir jetzt gerade sehen, ist halt so ein Tendenz zu sagen so, also die auch einfach ziemlich mit, wir haben jetzt langsam die Schnauze voll davon zu tun hat, zu sagen, so ja, der Staat soll jetzt mal hart durchgreifen. So nicht, er hat uns dunkel irgendwie so vor einem Jahr oder so. Ging es ja primär darum, wir wollen möglichst harte Corona-Regeln haben. Also das war dieser Söder-Spruch, wir wollen, soll möglichst hart sein und niemand hat darüber geredet, dass sie zielführend sein sollten oder effektiv sein sollten oder der Bayern-Putin.
Ich glaube Covid ist vor allem gar nicht so Ursache, sondern eher Brandverstärker. Also solange man diese ganzen, wie sagen wir mal, Baurechtsprobleme hat, wo dir der Staat und irgendwelche Behörden rein labern wollen, solange es mit wenig Reibung wegschaffbar ist, kann man das ja tolerieren als Bürger. Aber jetzt haben wir halt den zusätzlich noch, dass die Behörden alle dann wegen Covid ihre Termine halbiert oder noch weiter eingeschränkt haben. Das heißt, man hat nicht mal die Option, das einfach zu fressen. Die ganzen zusätzlichen Schikanen einfach machen wir jetzt halt. Weil du kriegst halt den Termin gar nicht mehr. Oder du kriegst einen Termin und der ist dann im September nächsten Jahres. Das heißt, ich glaube viel von der Wut, wir müssen jetzt hier endlich mal härtere Covid-Maßnahmen machen, kommt daher, dass die Leute einfach ihre Behördengänge aufgestaut haben und hoffen, dass wenn wir jetzt diesen Covid-Scheiß weg haben, dass sie dann auch einen neuen Personalausweis beantragen können. Ich fand es besonders krass, als ich dann hier im Impfcenter war und da stellte sich dann die Frage, ja was ist denn eigentlich, wenn der Pär so abgelaufen ist? Und das war so ein häufiges Problem, dass sie da eine vorgefertigte Antwort für haben. Ja, dann komm halt mit dem alten Pär, das macht nichts. Und das sagt jedoch aber eine ganze Menge über den Zustand der erstens der staatlichen infrastruktur und zweitens der Gesellschaft aus. Wenn einfach so viele Leute jetzt schon in Grunde Sachen einfach hinauszögern mussten, weil die infrastruktur das nicht ausgehalten hat. Ich glaube, da kommt eine Menge von diesem, wir brauchen jetzt eine Impfpflicht her. Weil den meisten Leuten ist das doch scheißegal, wie viele Leute sagen, sie seien geimpft und sie sind es nicht. Ja, weil nach dem Motto, es betrifft mich ja nicht, sondern der macht sich ja nur selber krank. Also ich meine, das stimmt nicht, aber so fühlt sich das ja an. Das könnte man alles viel besser wegignorieren, wenn man die andere Scheiße, die von Covid aufgehalten wurde, dann mal irgendwie geklärt kriegen würde. Oder Leute, Eltern, Eltern haben auch seit zwei Jahren im Grunde Dauerstress mit ihren Kindern in der Schule. Ja, ist die Schule jetzt offen? Kann die Klassenfahrt stattfinden, die geplant und schon eingezahlt wurde? Brauchen wir jetzt, ist jetzt Maskenpflicht? Dann muss das Kind vielleicht noch getestet werden. Ja, dann fällt irgendwie noch die Abi-Klausur aus, so hieß es. Und dann, naja, die Abi-Klausur muss aber trotzdem stattfinden. Das wäre sonst ungerecht. Die können ja dann nicht in die Uni. Und also dieser ganze Scheiß, das ist auch unglaublich zermürbend für die Eltern. Und ich glaube, viel von den Covid-Resort-Dubans sind einfach ein Seiteneffekt davon, dass die Leute diesen Scheiß endlich weg haben wollen und sich denken, wenn wir jetzt Covid-Impflicht machen, dann löst sich der Knoten auf. Was ich ja nicht glaube. Ich glaube, da gibt es nicht so viele Angestauerte. Selbst wenn Covid morgen weg wäre, hätten wir noch zwei Jahre mit aufräumen zu tun.
Ja, ohne Zweifel. Also ich meine, letzten Endes ist klar, wir brauchen halt irgendwie zumindest einen Staat, der halt irgendwie die basisinfrastruktur der Gesellschaft irgendwie so halbwegs am Laufen hält und die Aufgaben, die ihm übertragen wurden, einigermaßen effektiv erfüllt. Das Problem ist aber, dass die Strukturen, die sich da halt herausgebildet haben, eben auch um diese staatlichen Gelder. Also wenn wir uns jetzt angucken, wie hoch ist eigentlich die Staatsquote in den einzelnen Ländern, dann haben wir in den entwickelten großen Demokratien des Westens halt irgendwie so um die 60 Prozent sowas. Also ganz grob über den Daumen. Und daraus resultiert halt, also 60 Prozent des Bruttos sozial Produktes, muss man einfach klar sagen. Das ist also ein relativ überbordener Anteil. Da fallen natürlich eine Menge Sachen rein, wie irgendwie sowas wie Alterssicherung und Gesundheitswesen und so weiter. Aber die Gesundheitswesen, je nach Land, wie es organisiert ist. Aber letzten Endes ist halt klar der größte Batzen des Geldes, der halt irgendwie zu holen ist für Konzerne, ist irgendwie beim Staat verortet und dementsprechend steigt eben auch der Druck auf den Staat durch Lobbyismus, durch regulatory capture, also das absichtliche Beeinflussen von staatlicher Regulierung im Sinne der eigenen kommerziellen Interessen massiv an. Und also dieses ganze Phänomen, was wir schon mehrfach gesprochen haben, dass Ministerien sich halt irgendwie externe Hilfe von irgendwie so diesen Anwaltskanzleien und Beraterfirmen holen, die dann wiederum aber auch für die Großkonzerne arbeiten. Und weil sie das eigene fachliche Wissen nicht mehr aufbringen und im Zweifel auch keine politische Steuerung und keine politische Zielsetzung mehr haben. Ich glaube, dieses Problem lässt sich nicht mit mehr Staat lösen, sondern halt nur mit irgendwie sehr grundlegenden Reformen davon, wie der Staat eigentlich funktioniert. Und zum Teil glaube ich schon, dass wir an verschiedenen Stellen Alternativen zu staatlichen Organisationen brauchen. Einfach deswegen, weil der Staat einfach dazu neigt, jedes Problem durch noch mehr Regeln irgendwie versuchen in den Griff zu bekommen. Also was wir uns eher sehen im Steuerrecht zum Beispiel, ist ja, dass diese Komplexität, die da entstanden ist, hat ja einfach damit zu tun, dass immer wieder irgendwelche Schlupflöcher nachgepatcht wurden. Also dass halt irgendeine ursprünglich relativ einfache Regel mit irgendwie entweder Schlupfloch zu machen oder dem Versuch, irgendeine politische Steuerung über das Steuerwesen, also irgendeine Gruppe zu bevorteilen oder zu benachteiligen oder eine Handlungsweise irgendwie zu incentivieren oder nicht zu incentivieren, dass die halt in so Steuerregeln abgebildet wurde, die dann wiederum zu mehr Komplexität führen. Ich glaube, dieses Problem sehen wir in allen Möchen, in anderen Stellen auch, also gerade sowas wie soziale Sicherung oder ganzer arbeitslosen Wesen und so, hat halt irgendwie auch so unglaublich viel Bürokratiekomplexität. Also allein, wenn man sich diese Anträge anguckt, dass die, also das ist halt einfach nicht mehr, ohne, sagen wir mal, einen Kahlschlag und neu aufsetzende klaren Prioritäten zu regeln, aus meiner Sicht.
Man muss aber dazu sagen, fairerweise, dass das auch der Nummer-1-Hebel des Staates ist. Also der so viel, so viel Option hat der gar nicht. Also er kann jetzt natürlich per Gesetz irgendwie vorschreiben, dass Dinge gar nicht gemacht werden dürfen oder so was. Aber das ist ja relativ grob motorisch. Also es ist viel einfacher für den Staat, irgendwo die Steuern zu erheben oder zu senken, wenn sie da irgendwas wollen oder nicht wollen. Und die andere Sache, die sie machen können, ist Fördertöpfe aufmachen. Aber das ist auch nicht...
Sie können halt einfach direkt... Also ich meine, wenn der Staat irgendwas fördern will, dann soll er direkt Geld ausgeben.
Ja, das sind ja dann die Fördertöpfe, aber die fließen halt häufig auch nicht zu Leuten, die irgendwas machen wollen, sondern da gibt es ein ganz eigenes Ökosystem auf Abgreifern.
Was heißt Ökosystem? Die Großkonzerne haben halt alle Abteilungen, die sich genau darum kümmern, möglichst viel Förderung abzugreifen. Das ist ja auch die große Ironie, dass irgendwie so diese ganzen Helden, der libertären Ökonomen, so Peter Thiel oder Elon Musk oder so, deren Firmen haben Staatsquoten von über 50 Prozent.
Ja gut, der macht jetzt auch Raumfahrt. Das zählt ja nicht. Ja, das stimmt, natürlich. Aber es gibt auch, das sind nicht nur die Großkonzerne, es gibt auch Dienstleister, deren Angebot es ist, den Papierscheiß zu übernehmen für Fördertöpfe, die man abgreifen will, damit auch kleinere Firmen teilnehmen können.
Du kannst das nicht mehr anders machen. Also wenn du ein EU-Projekt, so ein EU-Förderprojekt machst, ich habe ja noch einige davon gemacht, kannst du de facto es nicht mehr schaffen, ohne einen spezialisierten Dienstleister, der sich um diese Bürokratieabwicklung kümmert und der schnappt irgendwie sowas zwischen 10 und 15 Prozent am Projekt-Gesamtvolumen.
Ja, das schafft Arbeitsplätze.
Du hast an allen möglichen Stellen so dieses Problem. Es gibt ja immer wieder so dieses Beispiel, ja wir müssen den Staat mehr digitalisieren und dann werden so die baltischen Länder, also gerade so Island oder so irgendwie als Beispiel hingestellt. Und wenn man sich das dann mal genauer anguckt, dann sieht man halt, dass die die haben halt quasi mit einem Greenfield angefangen. Die haben halt ihre gesamte staatliche Regulierung und ihre gesamten Gesetze und irgendwie auch wie Förderung designt ist und irgendwie wie Steuern designt ist, Sozialversicherung designt ist und so weiter und so fort. Das haben die halt alles einmal komplett neu machen können, nachdem sie halt irgendwie unabhängig geworden sind. Und das heißt, die haben da halt einfach nur irgendwie maximal 30 Jahre Ballast mit sich rumzutragen von angehäuften Regelungen, also häufiger auch weniger. Und die haben ihre Prozesse von Anfang an auch so gebaut, dass sie halt sinnvoll digitalisierbar sind. So und das ist halt so ein Ding, was halt immer wieder übersehen wird, dass halt wenn du halt irgendwie einen Scheißprozess digitalisierst, dann hast du einen digitalen Scheißprozess. Das heißt also, dieses ganze Digitalisierungsgeräte hat eigentlich aus meiner Sicht nur so halt mit irgendwie dem zu tun, was irgendwie in diesem Staat gerade schief läuft, sondern was man halt mal tun müsste, wäre halt an vielen Stellen einfach Clean Sheet machen und zu sagen so, wir fangen halt von vorne an und bauen das halt so einfach wie möglich und so gerade nicht wie möglich neu auf und ignorieren alle, die dann dabei heulen, weil sich gerade dann gewöhnt haben, dass sie in dieser oder jeden Regelungsnische jetzt gerade sich so irgendwie bequem gemacht haben.
Ja, meine Erfahrung mit der Digitalisierung ist, dass das im Grunde ein Outsourcing ist. Also jetzt aber nicht im herkömmlichen Sinne, sondern wenn ich früher einen Auftrag von einem Konzern annehmen wollte, dann haben die mir erstmal eine Mail geschickt, sie hatten gern ein Angebot. Dann hab ich ein Angebot gemacht und dann haben die das Angebot angenommen und beauftragt und das war alles. Und heutzutage musst du in irgendeinem verkackten Webportal einen Account anlegen, musst irgendwie Dutzende von eigentlich internen Bürokratiesachen, die die dann früher gemacht haben, die musst jetzt du als Beauftragter machen. Das heißt, die haben im Grunde ihren, die haben gar kein Interesse daran, die Prozesse zu entschlacken, weil deren Lösung ist ja bereits die Digitalisierung, die das dann auf ihre Kunden verschiebt. Das heißt, es geht nicht darum, Komplexität zu senken oder irgendwie, das ist gar nicht das Ziel. Das Ziel ist, dass ich das nicht mehr ausfüllen muss, als ich sag mal Großkonzern, irgendwie Telekom oder so, sondern dass die Leute, die von der Telekom Aufträge kriegen, die haben dann den Scheiß am Bein. Und damit ist für die Telekom aber das Problem gelöst, weil die haben einmal in diese Software investiert. Das waren die, die eh machen müssen. Und die Kosten trägt jetzt jemand anderes. Und so läuft das auch, wenn der Staat Digitalisierung macht. Also ich sag mal, das Problem ist ja nicht das Formular, wenn ich irgendwie eine Steuererklärung machen will, sondern das Problem ist, dass ich den Kontext nicht habe und deswegen einen Steuerberater brauche. Ob ich das jetzt irgendwie per Post oder per PDF abgebe, das ist nun das ist nicht die Sache, die das Komplex und kompliziert gemacht hat, sondern dass ich nicht weiß, wie ich die Werte da geschickt eintragen soll. Ja, das ist, das ist der komplexe Teil und der geht nicht weg, wenn ich das als PDF einschicken kann. So und genau. Das ist, das ist halt das Problem, dass niemand Interesse daran hat, die Komplexität zu senken, wenn es auch geht, die einfach auf jemand anderen zu verschieben.
Genau, und es dann Digitalisierung zu nennen.
Genau und dann sich noch zu feiern wegen der großen Fortschritte, die man erreicht hat. Ja, wir haben hier so eine kätzerische Frage stehen. Ist es legitim, ob der staatlichen Inkompetenz bei der Pandemie rumzureiten? Die folgt ja so ein bisschen aus unseren Ausführungen bisher, was man dann, wie man eigentlich den Staat sieht. Wie siehst du denn das?
Ja, also ich meine, man muss halt was sagen, dass der, also alles, was funktioniert hat oder fast alles, was funktioniert hat, waren immer einzelne Leute, die in, also aus dem, aus der Notwendigkeit heraus, dass man jetzt einfach tatsächlich mal handeln muss, sich quasi gesagt haben, okay, wir setzen uns jetzt mal über Regeln hinweg und machen jetzt einfach mal, also wie die Impfzentren in Berlin zum Beispiel aufgebaut wurden, war halt, dass die Teams, die sie da halt irgendwie für abgestellt haben, hatten explizit die Lizenz zum Bürokratieignorieren. Also den haben sie gesagt so, ja, okay, ihr bautet jetzt mal dahin so und ihr wisst ungefähr, was er tut und ihr könntet. Und wenn es dann hinterher bei der Bauabnahme irgendwelche Probleme gibt, dann regeln wir die dann so, aber nicht halt irgendwie mit irgendwie, ihr müsst erst mal einen Bestuhlungsplan einreichen. Wurde dann vier Wochen lang genehmigt irgendwie. Und sondern die haben halt einfach Leute genommen, die wissen, was sie tun und die haben sich da selber gemeldet und den Kram ausgerollt. Also nicht umsonst sind ja in der ersten Runde die Berliner Impfzentren zum großen Teil von Leuten aus der Berliner Party- und Festivalszene betrieben worden, die halt wissen, wie man halt mit großen Menschenmengen freundlich umgeht. Und halt jeder durchschleift durch so einen Prozess und dafür sorgt, dass halt irgendwie alles möglichst reibungslos funktioniert, weil die wissen halt, wenn du halt irgendwie so eine Fusion hast, auf die halt irgendwie gerade mal 30.000 Leute rein wollen, dann brauchst du halt eine Struktur, wie man halt irgendwie menschenfreundlich und zuvor kommt, da durchschleust. Und wenn sie das halt irgendwie dem Berliner Gesundheitsamt überlassen hätten, dann wär jetzt wahrscheinlich immer noch keine Infizientren. Das sind halt die Sachen, wo ich dann so sehe, das ist jetzt nicht so, dass der, dass halt das Kompetenz an sich mangelt, sondern die Leute, die halt die Kompetenzen haben, sind halt nicht an den richtigen Stellen, weil sie auch zum Teil überhaupt nicht incentiviert sind, für den Staat zu arbeiten. Also wenn man sich so die Verhältnisse in Berliner Amtsstuben anguckt.
Ja, hätte ich auch nicht. Weißt du, so wie die mich immer behandeln, habe ich doch überhaupt keinen Grund, die jetzt gut zu behandeln. Die können mal alle kacken gehen.
Genau.
Also ich verstehe das voll und ganz. Übrigens, die Kulturbranche hat da wirklich großartige Arbeit geleistet. Das möchte ich ja auch nochmal bekräftigen. Die auch so die Details stimmten. Ja, also zum Beispiel so, dass nachdem du da deine Spritze gekriegt hast, gibt es noch einen etwas längeren Weg nach draußen, der dann nicht irgendwie, hier ist gleich der Ausgang. Und das führt dafür, dass Leute, die einen anaphylaktischen Schock haben, den auf dem Weg nach draußen kriegen und nicht irgendwie in der U-Bahn. Man hat echt gemerkt, das hat jemand gemacht, der wusste, worauf er da gucken muss. Und nix davon war irgendwie so, wir lassen dich jetzt hier mal warten, weil wir können, wie so andere anderswo in Behörden, sondern immer, da stand dann einer und hat gesagt, ja, pass auf, da vorne kommt gleich, hier gibt es noch eine andere Schlange, probier die doch mal. Also wirklich hervorragende Arbeit.
Und dafür gesorgt haben, dass das irgendwie zu jedem Zeitpunkt jeder irgendwie gesehen wird. Also es gibt halt keinen Ort in dieser Impfzentrumswegführung, wo die Menschen, die da durchlaufen, halt nicht sofort jemand zur Seite haben, wenn sie ein Problem haben. Also es ist halt auch ein, muss man einfach klar sagen, da wurde halt einfach genug Personal investiert. Aber das ist halt wirklich eines der wenigen positiven Beispiels, muss man sagen, wo halt man sagen kann, okay, das hat halt funktioniert. Wo sich dann halt wieder verkackt haben, wie wir jetzt gerade sehen, ist halt bei der Impfstoffbereitstellung. Also das ist halt so ein, eigentlich in derselben Kategorie von irgendwie episches Verkacken einzusiedeln, wie dieser Ansage am Anfang so, ja, nee, Masken brauchen wir nicht, weil die könnte man ja falsch aufsetzen. Also das war ja, das war so für mich der Punkt, wo mein Vertrauen in diesen Staat zu Ende war.
Du, ich hab ja den Eindruck, das ist immer so, wenn der Staat irgendwas anschafft. Mit derartiger Regelmäßigkeit wird das verkackt, da frag ich mich dann langsam, ob das eigentlich noch mit Inkompetenz zu erklären ist. Ja, auch wenn die Bundeswehr kauft, die sind ja legendär dafür, dass ihre Anschaffung im Eimer ist oder irgendwie große Behörden brauchen, so Klopapier, der Bundestag braucht Klopapier. Also es geht von ganz oben nach ganz unten. Da gibt es eigentlich aus praktisch jedem Bereich irgendwie Geschichten, wo die krass zu viel gezahlt haben für irgendwas, was sich dann als Müll rausgestellt hat. Wurde dich ja echt fragst, wie viel Erfahrung braucht ihr eigentlich in der Beschaffung, bis euch so Anfängerfehler nicht mehr passieren?
Das interessante daran ist ja, dass ein Großteil dieser Komplexität in der Beschaffung hat ja somit zu Compliance-Regeln zu tun. Also dass sie halt einfach sich versucht haben, die das Raussieben von unseriösen Anbietern in Regeln zu formulieren und dabei natürlich übersehen haben, dass sie auf der Gegenseite halt mit intelligenten Menschen mit hoher krimineller Energie zu tun haben, die diese Regeln angucken, da halt irgendwie genügend Brainpower drauf werfen, um festzustellen, wie man sie umgehen kann. Und da kommt dann halt eben so was dabei raus, dass zwar der Anschaffungspreis niedrig ist, aber leider der Wartungsvertrag doppelt so teuer ist und so was. Also das sind dann, und dann werden diese Regeln wieder nachgezogen und dann findet wieder jemand eine Möglichkeit, sie zu umgehen. Anstatt halt zu sagen, so ja, wir geben halt da mal so dieses, diese Illusion der Beschaffungsgerechtigkeit irgendwie mal auf und sagen, wir wollen einfach den kompetentesten Anbieter haben und wir beurteilen denen halt Kraft irgendwie sinnvollen Menschenverstandes und demokratisch legitimierter Institutionen, die in der Lage sind zu beurteilen, ob ein Anbieter irgendwie seriös ist oder nicht. Das wäre ja irgendwie eine andere Möglichkeit zu sagen, so ok, du willst halt keine Korruption haben, deswegen verteilst du irgendwie die Beschaffungsentscheidung auf mehrere Leute, die so incentiviert sind, dass Korruption für die nicht eine gute Idee ist und nicht mit irgendwie die Byzantinen-Beschaffungsregularien, die dann nur von dem aller kriminellsten und seriösesten Anbieter erfüllt werden können, weil der halt irgendwie sich die entsprechenden Anwaltskanzlerin heuern kann, weil er weiß, dass seine Profitmarge so brutal hoch sein wird, dass er sich diese Anwälte leisten kann. Also was ja de facto der Fall ist.
Na also, man muss vielleicht sagen, das klingt jetzt alles so, als wären die das böswillig machen, aber ich hab mal mit jemandem gesprochen, der in einer großen Behörde für sowas, also nicht verantwortlich war, aber der da sozusagen Kunde war, der Sachen eingekauft hat. Und der hat erklärt, es gibt einfach diese, ich glaube sogar gesetzliche Regelung, dass der Staat beim billigsten Anbieter kaufen muss. Ja und das heißt eben, die Annahme ist, du schreibst in deine Anforderungen alles rein und dann ist aber auch egal, wer das liefert, weil ja die Anforderungen genau sagen, was du brauchst. Und das ist halt in der Praxis, führt das dazu, dass das Klopapier im Bundestag so Sandpapier irgendwie Industrieklopapier ist, weil die halt beim billigsten kaufen und das führt dann dazu, dass die irgendwann sagen, ok pass auf, ich mache euch ein Angebot, wir liefern euch irgendwie so Ödipussi mäßig diese riesen Menge Klopapier, dann können wir Rabatt geben, dann sind die billiger. So und dann hast du aber eine Einschränkung an die Lieferanten, weil nur wenige so eine große Menge liefern können. Und dann sind plötzlich nur noch zwei im Spiel, die treffen sich dann beim Golfen und machen gemeinsam aus, dass der Preis nach oben gehen könnte, damit haben wir beide was von. Und so funktioniert das dann. Das heißt, du hast am Ende irgendwelche endlosen Kataloge an Sachen, die das erfüllen muss, aber du hast im Grunde keine Gegenwehr, wenn es das nicht erfüllt. Also sagen wir mal, du kaufst jetzt irgendeine komplexe Software und schreibst in die Anforderungen, muss das, das, das und das können und dann liefert dir jemand so ein halbfertiges Demonstrator-Prototypen, irgendwie Ranz-Geraffel, was zwei von fünf, genau, mit fünf Blockchains, was irgendwie zwei von fünf Anforderungen so ein bisschen halb irgendwie am Rande erfüllt und erzählt dir, naja, pass auf, wir haben jetzt hier zwei Jahre Projekt schon hinter uns, ihr könnt es jetzt irgendwie nicht abnehmen, aber dann habt ihr zwei Jahre verloren oder ihr gebt uns mehr Geld und dann können wir das ja noch reparieren. Und dann sagt der Staat natürlich, ja scheiß die zwei Jahre, das ist irgendwie die halbe Länge des Lebens Naturperiodes, das können wir uns nicht leisten, das wegzuschmeißen und so läuft das dann. Aber das ist nicht so, dass da irgendwie böse Leute die Anforderungen schlimm machen, sondern das folgt aus dem System. Das Spiel, die Anreize in dem Spiel sorgen dafür, dass es so abläuft. Das ist nicht irgendwie der Grinch im Keller.
Nee, den Grinch im Keller sehe ich da auch nicht. Also abgesehen davon, das ist natürlich gerade ein Beschaffungswesen, immer noch die schöne Tradition von Beratungsverträgen nach dem Ende der Beamtendienstzeit gibt.
Braucht uns Pflege.
Insbesondere im Bauwesen und in der Militärbeschaffung ist sowas ja doch durchaus sehr häufig anzutreffen, dass dann die entsprechenden leitenden Beamten noch irgendwie nach Ende ihrer Beamtenlaubbahn noch irgendwie ein paar schöne Jahre als Berater von den Konzernen, denen sie die Aufträge zugeschanzt haben, verbringen, wo es auch nicht wirklich eine gesetzliche Handhabe gegen gibt. Das ist halt die High-Level-Korruption, wie sie halt in Deutschland stattfindet. Aber ich glaube, das Problem ist letztendlich auch, dass der Staat an sich mit seiner Struktur, wie er arbeitet, nämlich halt auf der einen Seite halt einen Beamtenapparat, der, sagen wir mal, nicht unbedingt flexibel ist, um es mal freundlich zu formulieren, und auf der anderen Seite auch sehr, sehr vielen Regeln unterliegt und sehr, sehr vielen Einschränkungen unterliegt. Nicht in der Lage ist, halt hinreichend flexibel zu arbeiten. Auf der anderen Seite wurde es dann abgewälzt, dadurch, dass dann halt viele Aufgaben, wie zum Beispiel Jugendbetreuung, Sozialarbeit und so weiter, denn de facto von unterbezahlten Kräften erledigt werden, die dann halt immer nur sehr temporäre Anstellungsverhältnisse haben. Also, dass halt auch so ein brutales Gefälle zwischen den Klassen da ist, ist, glaube ich, ein Zeichen dafür, dass man andere Wege finden muss, diesen Umgang mit staatlichen Aufgaben zu regeln. Und mein Lieblingsidee dabei ist zu sein, wenn wir Aufgaben haben, die im Interesse der Öffentlichkeit nicht kommerziell, also nicht mit Profitinteresse, abgewickelt werden sollten, dann brauchen wir dafür eine Neuerfindung von dem, was mal die öffentlich-rechtlichen Anstalten waren. Also öffentlich-rechtliche Anstalten im Sinne sowas wie die ARD wurden ja mal abwunden als Institution, weil man sagt, okay, wir wollen etwas haben, was im Interesse der Öffentlichkeit unter sowas ähnliches wie demokratischer Kontrolle, was dann halt diese komischen Rundfunkräte geworden sind, agiert und nicht profitorientiert ist, sondern halt eine klar umrissene, klar begrenzte Aufgabe für eine klar definierte Menge Geld erledigt, die halt dann angemessen sein muss der Erfüllung dieser Aufgabe. Das Problem ist halt, dass durch die lange Laufzeit von dem, was wir jetzt haben in diesen öffentlich-rechtlichen Institutionen, die jetzt existieren, also sprich insbesondere die Rundfunkanstalten, hat sich dann natürlich auch eine gigantische Bürokratie rausgebildet, ein großer Apparat, eine Menge Traditionen, eine Menge auch Pensionsverpflichtungen und ähnliche Dinge, die dazu führen, dass dieser Begriff öffentlich-rechtlich halt inzwischen total kontaminiert ist. Also du kannst, wenn du öffentlich-rechtlich sagst, denken alle sofort an Rundfunkgebühren und irgendwie den, was da halt irgendwie alles schief läuft. Aber im Prinzip ist es ja eigentlich eine gute Idee, also eigentlich zu sagen, so okay, wir wollen demokratisch kontrollierte Strukturen haben, die eine spezifische Aufgabe erledigen, ohne der Staat zu sein. Weil wenn der Staat ins Spiel kommt, dann hast du halt gleich immer auch so einen Zusammenfluss von allen möglichen anderen Aufgaben, dann hast du plötzlich die In- und Sicherheitspolitiker, die irgendwie die Daten wollen, dann hast du halt irgendwie das Finanzamt, das überall reingucken will, dann hast du halt irgendwie die ganze Komplexität von Leuten, die dann auch politische Gerechtigkeit in diese oder jede Richtung in solche Regeln rein designen wollen. Also ist quasi so ein, also dieses Mission Creep Ding ist eigentlich quasi unvermeidlich dann an der Stelle. Dann hast du sowas wie im Beschaffungswesen müssen dann halt irgendwie bestimmte Firmen, die halt besonders grün oder ökologisch oder von, in Amiland hat man es ja gerne von Minderheiten betrieben werden, die dann halt irgendwie bevorzugt werden müssen und so weiter. So wurde halt quasi dieses ganze, diese ganze Idee von hier und da könnte man nochmal mehr Gerechtigkeit oder Erfüllung von Klimazielen oder was auch immer irgendwie mit reinbauen, führt dann halt dazu, dass du halt noch mehr Komplexität reinkriegst. Ich denke stattdessen wäre es sinnvoll zu sagen, es gibt für unterschiedliche Aufgaben, also alle gehen natürlich nicht, es gibt natürlich eine Menge heutliche Aufgaben, aber für viele Aufgaben braucht man neue Institutionen, die nicht so gigantische Apparate sind, die halt relativ klein sind, die eine Struktur haben, die auch flexibel ist, wo man halt auf neue Anforderungen relativ schnell reagieren kann und nicht leider keine neuen Leute einstellen muss, weil es nicht mehr genug Beamten-Laufbahn-Posten in dem Budgetansatz für die nächsten zehn Jahre gibt, weil da noch zu viele andere Alte rumsitzen, die halt irgendwie noch irgendwie sich da als Verdiener gefeuert werden können. Die können halt nicht gefeuert werden, so ne, also deshalb muss ich auch nicht feuern, aber muss ich halt sinnvoll irgendwo verwenden und wenn sie halt für die Aufgabe nicht verwendbar sind, sollte man sie woanders hinschieben, aber das findet halt in der Regel natürlich nicht statt. Und das ist halt so eine, glaube ich, so eine Flexibilisierung der Struktur, wäre da sinnvoll im Sinne von Aufgaben nicht an Unternehmen geben, das kennen wir ja schon, so in dem Umblick, wo dann da irgendwie Arvato und sonstige Dienstleister halt in diesem Public-Private-Partnership-Rahmen involviert werden mit der Ansage, wir können das alles viel effizienter, führt es halt nur dazu, dass die Effizienzgewinner halt am Ende als Profite in Taschen von diesen Unternehmen landen, nicht darin, dass irgendwas besser funktioniert. Ich denke, dass man deswegen halt einen neuen Ansatz braucht, der dem gerecht wird zu sagen, wir brauchen infrastruktur, die im Sinne der Öffentlichkeit, im Sinne der Gesellschaft betrieben wird, von der Gesellschaft finanziert. Aber mit einem klaren Riss in Aufgabenspektrum und mit einer der entsprechenden demokratischen Kontrolle, die nicht diesen riesigen Umweg über das Parlament und die Gesetzgebungsverfahren und so weiter und so fort nimmt, sondern halt im Zweifel ein bisschen direkter ist. Und die ursprünglichen Ansätze gab es ja mal. Also ihr erinnert euch vielleicht dunkel, wenn ihr gelegentlich bekommt, ihr von eurer Krankenkasse zum Beispiel oder auch von der Rentenkasse so dieses Ding mit irgendwie so, wir müssen hier mal eine Wahl machen und da gibt es so einen Beirat, der irgendwie diese Rentenkasse kontrolliert und du kannst jetzt dann mal wählen. Da haben wir gerade Wahlbeteiligung von glaube ich 6 Prozent oder 7 Prozent oder so, weil niemand so richtig versteht, was es eigentlich ist. Aber es lohnt da tatsächlich mal hinzugucken, weil die ursprüngliche Idee da eben war zu sagen, es ist halt nicht der Staat, es sind halt keine Beamten zusammen, es ist halt eine Struktur, die im Sinne der Öffentlichkeit kontrolliert von der Öffentlichkeit agiert. Und ich glaube, in die Richtung muss man mal wieder weiterdenken, muss man wieder mal neue Strukturen überlegen und erfinden, die möglicherweise viel effizienter daran sein können, viel flexibler daran sein können, halt Aufgaben, die momentan der Staat erledigt oder sich als seine Aufgabe betrachtet viel besser erledigen können. So und dazu gehört für mich zum Beispiel halt so was wie infrastruktur. So was wie die Bahn in eine Gesellschaft zu tun, die Profit erwirtschaften muss, ist halt eigentlich Bullshit. Also die Bahn ist halt die einzige Aufgabe, die die Bahn hat, sie muss funktionieren. Und nicht irgendwie auch noch Gewinn abwerfen. Also alles, wo halt natürliche Monopole sind, aus meiner Sicht sind halt infrastruktureinrichtungen, die in solche öffentlich-rechtlichen Gesellschaften gehören.
Es gibt halt ein paar Gegenindikationen, die bisher dafür gesorgt haben, dass das nicht geklappt hat. Also erstens hast du natürlich so die FDP, die einfach behauptet, na ja, wenn der Staat da irgendwie die Finger drin hat, ist das immer ineffizienter, als wenn es die Privatwirtschaft macht.
Na deswegen sag ich, es sollte eben nicht der Staat, deswegen öffentlich-rechtlich heißt eben nicht der Staat. Das ist halt der wichtige Punkt dabei. Das muss man nicht verwischen.
Ja, nein, aber pass auf, damit hast du was zu tun, wenn du in die Richtung denkst. Dann hast du die FDP am Arsch. Als nächstes hast du die EU am Arsch, weil irgendein privatwirtschaftlicher, also bei den Verlagen gab es das gerade, die haben halt gesagt, ja pass auf, wenn irgendwie die ARD Sachen online veröffentlichen darf, dann ist das ein Eingriff in unser Geschäftsmodell und das ist eine Marktbarriere. Und dann kommt dann die EU und sagt, das geht aber nicht. Also das heißt, schon in dem existierenden Gerüst, in dem wir uns bewegen, gibt es Kontaindikationen dafür, das so richtig zu machen. Weil einfach die EU irgendwann entschieden hat, dass primar die wichtigste Sache, um die es hierher geht, ist der gemeinsame Markt. So ist die EU einfach verstanden. Und das ist heute noch die höchste Priorität höher als der, ansonsten zum Beispiel die Gesundheit der Bürger. Ja, so eine Marktverzerrung ist die die größte Sache, die die EU ernten kann. Und da sind sie dann auch immer vergleichsweise schnell. Also ich will nicht sagen, dass wir das bisher nicht haben, liegt nicht darin, dass es keiner wollte.
Doch.
Sondern es gab Versuche und die sind alle dahin losgegangen.
Das glaube ich nicht. Ich glaube, das Problem ist halt eher, dass die Vorstellungen, die man jetzt halt momentan davon hat, sind halt beeinflusst von den existierenden Institutionen, die in ihrer Verkrustung und in ihrem Alter tatsächlich nicht effektiv in der Lage sind, das zu tun. Und ich glaube, das muss man halt einfach wirklich neu erfinden. Und da muss man halt die entsprechenden gesetzlichen Voraussetzungen für schaffen. Da muss man dann dafür sorgen, dass es halt irgendwie eine, keine Ahnung, eine öffentlich-rechtliche Institution gibt, die dafür zuständig ist, halt irgendwie sichere Open-Source-Software zu fördern. Zum Beispiel wäre halt so eines meiner Lieblingsthemen halt, wo man sagt, okay, das sollte nicht der Staat sein, weil der Staat halt dann immer noch andere Interessen, sondern sollte halt eine Struktur sein, die ein klar umrissendes Aufgabensspektrum hat, aber halt eben demokratisch kontrolliert ist.
Und ich bin da ganz bei dir. Nicht, dass wir uns hier falsch verstehen, ich bin ganz bei dir. Aber wenn du dir zum Beispiel anguckst, wie der Staat darstellt, was aus ihrer Sicht eine Private-Public-Partnership ist, das ist genau, was du hier erzählst. Also jetzt nicht von den juristischen Details her, aber von den Zielen.
Von den ökonomischen Details.
Das ist genau das, was sie eigentlich haben wollten. Ja, funktioniert ja auch nicht. Aber das ist nicht so, dass es keiner wollte. Sondern die paar Ansätze, die es in die Richtung gab, sind halt pervertiert worden von den Lobbyisten. Da hätte man sich mehr gegenstimmen müssen. Also es ist kein Selbstläufer.
Das ist überhaupt kein Selbstläufer. Klar, das ist halt eines der dicksten politischen Bretter, die gerade zu bohren sind. Das war vollkommen richtig.
Da müsste halt mein Name zumindest anfangen.
Naja, vor allen Dingen müsste man halt diese Scheu dafür überwinden, halt irgendwie andere Strukturen zu denken. Also andere Möglichkeiten zu denken, wie man Aufgaben im Sinne der Gemeinschaft organisieren kann. Das ist halt, glaube ich, so ein Ding, wo... Also wir haben da auch, glaube ich, so eine mentale Vermischung zwischen den europäischen und den angelsächsischen Traditionen. Also wo die angelsächsischen Traditionen sind ja auf der Oberfläche irgendwie möglichst viel irgendwie privatwirtschaftlich abzuwickeln. De facto ist es aber so, dass die Staatsquoten da genauso hoch sind und irgendwie auch unter irgendwie Reagan und Thatcher am Ende gestiegen sind, weil sie dann halt einfach gesagt haben, so wie der Staat nimmt die Kohle ein und verteilt sie dann an private Unternehmen. Das halt dieses reguläre Capture-Problem nochmal dramatisch verschärft hat. Und was wir halt stattdessen brauchen, ist halt dann ja einfach eine Entscheidung zu sagen, so wie viel ist uns dann eigentlich diese Aufgabe wert? Also was wollen wir denn als Gesellschaft ausgeben für zum Beispiel, keine Ahnung, klimaneutral öffentlichen Transport?
Ja. Ja, also ich bin wie gesagt auch voll dafür. Aber du musst es halt auch aus Sicht von den Staatssäen, der das dann einleiten müsste. Ja, und der denkt sich, okay, ich habe hier erst mal nur Nachteile. Also ich habe irgendwie Ausgaben für das Kapital und ich gebe auch noch die Macht ab. Das heißt, ich kann, wenn das nicht gut läuft, alles, was ich tun kann, ist aufhören, da mehr Geld hinzuwerfen. Aber ich habe auch keinen Hebel, weil das war ja die Idee, dass da eben kein Hebel ist, über den der Staat es korrumpieren kann. Aber das heißt eben auch, der Staat hat keinen Hebel, um gute Änderungen durchzuführen. Aus Sicht der Politik ist das erst mal reiner Nachteil. Oder sagen wir mal so, muss man halt dran glauben. Und das kann ich schon verstehen, wenn die das lieber nicht machen wollen. Auf der anderen Seite haben die kein Problem, die Autobahngesellschaft zu gründen, die ja auch jetzt schon absehbar ein Riesendesaster wird.
Was halt auch damit zu tun hat, dass die traditionelle, intellektuelle Diversierung des Staates, also sich halt mehr und mehr aus der intellektuellen Fähigkeit zurückzuziehen, bestimmte Probleme zu lösen, führt eben auch dazu, dass die Beurteilungsfähigkeit halt einfach abnimmt. Also die barfinisten natürlich ein super Beispiel für einen. Also die, die sich dann halt einfach wirklich irgendwelche Banker, die halt vorher gegen sie gearbeitet haben, anstellen müssen, um überhaupt zu verstehen, was jetzt da eigentlich passiert. Das ist halt so, wo man sich denkt, so das kann doch eigentlich nicht sein. Und also aus meiner Sicht ist halt so, dass der, dass die monolithischer der Staat wird und die mehr Strukturen er aufbaut, die quasi unter staatliche Kontrolle sind, dass das schlimmer wird halt das Problem an der Stelle. Und da werden wir früher oder später wieder an so einen Punkt kommen, wenn jetzt also der Trend geht ja gerade hin zu wir wollen mehr Staat und der Staat soll mehr Aufgaben übernehmen, weil irgendwie die Kapitalisten irgendwie nutzen nur jede Möglichkeit, uns abzuzocken. Wird halt wieder zu dem, das ist quasi, das Pendel schwingt da quasi zurück. Dann haben wir wieder so eine Struktur, wo halt irgendwie diese ganze, naja, also was, wie ist diese lustige britische Serie? Yes Minister.
Yes Minister.
Genau. Was halt, also Yes Minister war ja quasi der propagandistische, also das propagandistische Mittel, was halt zur Zerstörung des Public Service in Großbritannien verwendet wurde, in dem halt die Zustände darin halt portraitiert wurden und nach allem, was man weiß, jetzt nicht unbedingt falsch portraitiert wurden.
Das ist ja schon durchaus akkurat.
Genau. Das ist halt so ein Ding, da werden wir dann halt wieder hinkommen. Und dann wird es halt wieder irgendwann so ein Backlash in diese Richtung geben, der halt dann wieder, also das ist dann wahrscheinlich noch 10, 20 Jahre hin, aber das wird dann halt wieder zu so einem, wir müssen jetzt wieder mehr privatisieren und irgendwie so zu diesem Quatsch führen. Da den Ausweg zu finden und zu sagen, man braucht halt irgendwie Lösungen, die nicht monolithisch sind, ist, glaube ich, ganz gut. Aber ein Problem, was wir in Deutschland haben, ist halt dieses ganze Föderalismus-Ding, was wir auch bei der Corona-Sache sehr stark gesehen haben, dass halt einfach die Handlungs- und Entscheidungsfähigkeit staatlicher Institutionen durch ihre interne Komplexität halt irgendwie auch dramatisch reduziert ist. Also wo halt einfach der, es halt irgendwie keine Instanz gibt, die halt, der man halt einfach temporär mal die Macht gibt, zu sagen, wir lösen jetzt mal dieses Problem.
Aber es ist doch ein Feature, das wollten wir doch so.
Naja, außerhalb von der Krise ist es ja korrekt, aber letzten Endes ist es halt so, dass wenn du halt eine Krise hast, und zwar eine ernsthafte Krise, dann brauchst du halt eine Möglichkeit, dich Entscheidungen relativ schnell zu treffen und die dann halt auch umzusetzen. Und das Problem kann man ja zurücktreiben bis irgendwie zur Römischen Republik, wo dann halt die Imperatoren dann irgendwann dadurch an die Macht kamen, dass sie halt irgendwie ihre Krisenautorisierung für, wir müssen jetzt mal schnell uns mit dieser Krise oder diesem Krieg auseinandersetzen, verstetigt haben. Also die Gefahr ist natürlich da, das ist vollkommen klar. Diese föderale Struktur zur Diktaturvermeidung hat natürlich ihre Vorteile, aber ich glaube, dass insbesondere halt in solchen Situationen, wo man halt echt mal schnell handeln muss, weil auf der anderen Seite halt eine Exponentialfunktion lauert, da braucht man halt einfach andere Mittel und Wege für.
Naja, also ich habe neulich so ein Artikel gelesen von einem Politinsider, der meinte, die Politik sei im Wesentlichen gelähmt, weil alle großen Entscheidungen auch vom Bundesrat abgenickt werden müssen. Und das heißt, die Mehrheit da kriegst du halt nur, wenn sich im Grunde alle einig sind. Das heißt, wir haben eine reine irgendwie Aussitzen und alles bis zur Krise abwarten Demokratie hier. Und am Ende, wenn die Hütte brennt, dann gibt es plötzlich irgendwie die Genehmigung, weil dann auch der letzte irgendwie Lokalfuzzi im Bundesrat zustimmt. Und das hat, das klingt jetzt alles furchtbar, aber es ist eigentlich erstens Diktaturvermeidung und zweitens heißt es, dass der Staat im Wesentlichen die Dinge tut, die auch tatsächlich die Bürger gerne wollen. Ja, und da muss man jetzt ein bisschen aufpassen, weil sowohl der Staat als auch die Bürger gerne darüber lügen, was sie eigentlich wollen. Das heißt, wir haben hier ein Mittel zur indirekten Konsensfindung zwischen unehrlichen Leuten, was ja eigentlich ein sehr schweres, sehr schwieriges Problem ist. Ein Wunder, dass da noch keiner die Blockchain vorgeschlagen hat.
Genau, ich meine, du wolltest sagen, der einzig sinnvolle Anwendungszweck für eine Blockchain ist doch genau so was.
Ja, jedenfalls, das Problem ist halt, die Politik hat nur indirekte Messmethoden, nämlich umfragen. Die fragen halt Bürger, was hättet ihr denn gern? Und dann sagen die Bürger, ja, wir möchten gern mehr Asylbewerber reinlassen, weil keiner irgendwie der rassistische Arsch sein will, der gesagt hat, wir wollen keine Asylanten haben. Aber wenn es dann darum geht, eine Unterkunft zu bauen, dann sagt halt doch jeder Landkreis, ja, aber nicht bei uns. Das heißt, alle Teilnehmer lügen sich im Kreis an und die Politik kann am Ende nur die Sachen tun, wo tatsächlich Mehrheiten für existieren. Und das ist ja eigentlich ein Feature, was wir auch so wollten. Also absichtlich. Wir wollten vermeiden, dass irgendeine Partei, wie eben unter den Nazis damals, mit einer knappen Mehrheit irgendwie durchsegeln kann. Und als Beispiel wäre zum Beispiel die Atomenergie geeignet. Da haben ja auch jahrzehntelang alle davon geredet, dass sie das gerne loswerden wollen. Aber erst als wirklich klar waren nach Fukushima, dass die Leute das wirklich alle jetzt nicht mehr haben wollen, da ging es dann auch ganz schnell. Ja und so ist das mit vielen Sachen, wenn man wenn man drauf achtet. Da gibt es halt viel Gerede. Aber der Zeitpunkt, an dem sich dann wirklich was bewegt, ist der, bei dem auch die Mehrheiten klar waren. Also wie zum Beispiel auch sowas wie die die gleichgeschlechtliche Ehe ist auch eine Sache, die hat ewig gedauert und alle haben die ganze Zeit waren der Meinung, das ist schon, das wird irgendwann kommen und eigentlich ist es auch das Richtige. Aber erst als wirklich nicht mehr zu diskutieren war, ob jetzt die Mehrheit dafür ist, da ist es dann auch geschehen.
Oder jetzt mit der Cannabis-Legalisierung.
Genau, die Cannabis ist auch so was. Und dann denke ich mir doch, okay, dann heißt es doch aber, dass sich unsere einfach unsere Erwartungshaltung auch danach richten sollte, dass wir einfach gucken, dass wir dann die Themen so klar in die Mehrheit kriegen, dass die Politik das dann auch tut. Und das heißt aber auf der anderen Seite, dass man jetzt argumentieren könnte, okay, diese ganze Impfgeschichte vielleicht gibt es da gar nicht so viele von. Vielleicht ist das völlig übertrieben, da kommen wir nachher noch zu, wenn es um Statistik geht. Aber so die Frage ist halt, sieht das nicht einfach nach mehr Widerstand aus, als es tatsächlich ist, weil natürlich so eine Demo, was ist, über das die Medien berichten, weil die Leute halt ein Forum kriegen, wo sie ihren Blabla ausbreiten können. Das heißt, diese Messung ist halt schwierig. Wie viele Leute gibt es denn jetzt wirklich, die nicht geimpft werden wollen? Oder ist das nur irgendwie eine Minderheit aus dreieinhalb Leuten, die irgendwie Facebook-Klons gekauft haben oder so? Das heißt, das ist meines Erachtens auch der Grund, warum die Politik die Anti-Covid-Restriktions-Demos zugelassen hat, weil sie halt als einzige Messung das sozusagen haben, daraus hochzurechnen, wie viel es denn wirklich gibt, die dagegen sind. Aber gut, das ist Spekulation.
Na gut, ich meine, da sind die umfragen relativ klar jetzt. Also wir sind ja von, also bei der Impfpflicht, also ich halte Impfpflicht nach wie vor für Quatsch, aber die Impfpflicht wird inzwischen von zwei Dritteln der befragten in den aktuellen umfragen befürwortet. So kurze Anmerkung, warum ich Impfpflicht für Quatsch halte, der Staat ist einfach schlicht nicht in der Lage, die durchzusetzen, zu kontrollieren, weil er momentan einfach nicht mal mehr weiß, wer jetzt eigentlich geimpft ist, sondern was der Staat halt...
Na die ganze Zeit schon nicht. Es gibt da kein impfregister in Deutschland. Und jetzt fallen noch noch der Reihe nach die Polizeibezirke aus. Weiß nicht, ob du das gesehen hattest. Da ging so eine Artikel rum, weil die halt auch Covid kriegen. Klar, wenn die irgendwie auf Demos rumhängen von Covid-Leugnern, klar haben die dann irgendwann infizieren, die sich auch. Oder gibt es jetzt ganz Ausfälle?
Na gut, aber das ist halt auch tatsächlich so ein Punkt. Also eigentlich sollte der Staat ja nur Regelungen treffen, die er zum einen halt nach den Maßgaben des Grundgesetzes argumentieren kann. Also dass sie halt sinnvoll sind.
Hätte ich gern als erstes.
Die sinnvoll und nützlichsten. Angemessen sinnvoll. Also ist halt irgendwie so. Und Angemessenheit heißt ja immer auch, dass es halt irgendwie das mildeste Mittel zum Erreichen des Ziels sein muss. Und tatsächlich ist es halt so, dass de facto würde eine Impfpflicht halt nur irgendwie in 2G mit Regeldurchsetzung bedeuten. Das könnte man heute schon haben. Da müsste man jetzt irgendwie sich diese gesamte Debatte einfach nicht gönnen. So, das wäre halt also in dem Augenblick, wo man halt einfach flächendeckend 2G macht und halt irgendwie die die Regeln einigermaßen stringent durchzieht, hätte man das Problem halt auch vom Tisch. Und man wird halt, also wir sind halt momentan in dem Punkt, wo ich glaube, die, also wenn man die unfragen so einigermaßen zusammenzieht, dann hat man so in der Größenordnung zwischen 10 und 15 Prozent der Leute, die halt irgendwie sich auf gar keinen Fall impfen lassen wollen. So das halt so trifft irgendwie relativ klar zusammen mit irgendwie so der Kernwählerschaft der AfD. Die Prozentzahl nur verteilt sich halt über ein paar mehr Parteien. Also bei Gründen FDP ist halt noch ein bisschen mehr. Aber das ist halt so ein...
Naja, aber warte mal. Kann das nicht sein, dass das einfach die Messmethode der Politik ist, dass sie jetzt, um rauszufinden, ob sie 2G-Enforcement machen sollen, dass sie die Bevölkerung fragen, was haltet ihr von Impfpflicht? Und wenn da der Widerstand klein genug ist, dann macht man 2G-Enforcement und sagt, ah, guck mal, wir sind hier keine Extremisten. Die Impfpflicht haben wir nicht gemacht.
Ist durchaus möglich, das ist möglich, ja.
So, das ist meine Theorie gerade, dass wir das gerade beobachten. Aber was mir wichtig war an der Stelle, es geht hier nicht um die Moral, also die Erwartung, dass der Staat das moralisch oder ethisch Richtige tut, auch gegen den Willen der Bevölkerung, das ist Unfug, denn der Staat, die Anreize für alle Spieler im Staat sind nicht so ausgelegt, dass das auch nur auf der Liste der Ziele ist. Ja, die möchten gern das tun, was mehrheitsfähig ist und vielleicht können sie dafür sorgen, dass das, was sie für richtig halten, für moralisch angemessen, dass das mehrheitsfähig wird, aber halt mehr auch nicht. Also der Staat kann nicht gegen die Bevölkerung irgendwie moralische Dinge durchsetzen.
Ja, das ist ein wichtiger Grundsatz. Der ist ein Kern, dass sich der Staat aus moralischen Beurteilungen rauszuhalten hat, weil die Moral ist relativ starken Schwankungen unterworfen. Wenn man an die Gesetzgebungen bis in die 70er Jahre hinein denkt, was Schwule angeht oder uneheliche Partnerschaften und ähnliche Dinge, dann ist es ja so, dass diese Gesetze, die dann da gemacht wurden, um eine öffentliche Moral durchzusetzen, haben ja halt irgendwie schweres Leid irgendwie überall verursacht. Und sind dann halt irgendwie erst nachdem sie abgeschafft wurden, hat man eigentlich wirklich verstanden, was das halt eigentlich für ein Problem war, dass der Staat sich da zum Hüter der Moral gemacht hat. Aber dieses Problem...
Ja, keine Frage.
Dieses Problem wird dann aber tatsächlich noch mal richtig akut beim Thema Klimawandel. Also in dem Umblick, wo man halt irgendwie sagt, okay, wir haben jetzt irgendwie ein übergreifendes Ziel, nämlich halt irgendwie unsere CO2-Emissionen, Methanemissionen zu drücken. Und die sind halt nicht mehr durchsetzbar, nur mit Anreizsystem alleine. Soll der Staat dann tatsächlich irgendwie Zwang anwenden, um dieses Ziel zu erreichen? Das ist ein nicht ganz triviales Problem.
Ja, ich wollte noch darauf hinweisen, dass es da durchaus verschiedene Sichten drauf gibt, ob der Staat moralisch handeln sollte oder nicht. Es gibt nämlich auch die Sicht, die früher unter Eliten sehr populär war. So, das Wahlvolk ist eigentlich blöde, blöde, inkompetent, schlecht informiert. Es ist unsere Aufgabe, ihnen genau so viel Informationen zu geben, dass sie uns machen lassen. Und wir tun dann das Richtige, aus unserer Sicht natürlich. Aber wir sind ja die Eliten. Das heißt, was wir für richtig halten, ist auch richtig. Also das gab es auch lange Jahre.
Das gibt es auch immer noch. Das ist tatsächlich unter höheren Wirtschaftskadern immer noch eine sehr verbreitete Ansicht.
Ja, allein, dass es wirtschaftsweise gibt bei uns, sagt ja schon alles aus über diese. Ja, gut. Aber jedenfalls, das wollte ich gerne noch mal klar sagen, die Idee, die Erwartung, dass der Staat das moralisch Richtige gegen seine Bürger tut, ist unrealistischer Blödsinn. Ja, also das heißt, den Staat jetzt dafür zu kritisieren, dass er irgendwie Sachen nicht gegen seine Bevölkerung durchgesetzt hat, so funktioniert das nicht. Ihr müsst dann die Bevölkerung mobilisiert kriegen, damit der Staat sieht, das wollen alle und dann wird das geschehen. Dann geht auch so was wie ein Atomausstieg. Gut, den haben wir jetzt immer noch nur halb, weil es die CDU die Umsetzung gemacht hat, die können ja nichts. Naja, so funktioniert das und nur so. Du musst erst die Bevölkerung in einen Norden und dann folgt die Politik. Die Politik ist in der Beziehung, folgt sie auch tatsächlich dem ursprünglichen Ideal, dass sie nämlich bei Auftrag des Souveräntes ist und der Souverän ist das Volk. Die Politik würde gerade ab und zu mal die getun, die das Volk nicht will, aber es ist eigentlich jedes Mal ein Riesenreinfall, endlose Zankereien und am Ende wird es dann von irgendeinem Gericht kassiert.
Naja, das finde ich eine sehr optimistische Betrachtung.
Naja, ein bisschen Optimismus ist so als aufrechterhaltensatz, können wir das hier nicht machen.
Also ich meine, wenn man das jetzt bei den Corona-Maßnahmen betrachtet, das hat ja weder was mit Rationalen noch mit Abbildungen des Bevölkerungswillens zu tun.
Ja, aber da hilft Spieletheorie. Aus Sicht der Politik ist es so, dass die halt nicht Corona besiegen müssen, sondern sie müssen ihre Legislaturperiode zu Ende schaffen. Und da war einfach bei der CDU überhaupt kein Anreiz für den Herbst zu planen, weil da war die nächste Regierung drin. Das heißt, die mussten nur so ein bisschen irgendwie das nicht komplett verkacken, damit es noch irgendwie einen Hebel gibt, falls sie wiedergewählt werden. Aber das ist kein Zufall, dass die Ampel jetzt praktisch bei Null anfängt, sondern das ist halt unser unser Schrottsystem, was da nicht längerfristige Planung zulässt.
Ja gut, ich meine, ich rede jetzt auch eher tatsächlich irgendwie, was sie da irgendwie beim letzten Lockdown veranstaltet haben. Also, das muss ich einfach...
Ja, aber das lässt sich alles erklären, durch verschiedene psychologische Effekte, zu denen wir gleich noch kommen in Sektion 2.
Naja, nee, also ich glaube, da bin ich tatsächlich ein bisschen anderer Meinung, weil halt sowas wie irgendwie diese, also gerade in Berlin hier so, das Ordnungsamt auf Leute hetzen, die irgendwie nachts um zwei alleine auf einer Straße sind und denen eine Strafe reindrücken und die jetzt auch immer noch kassieren wollen, weil sie halt irgendwie alleine auf der Straße keine Maske getragen haben. Also das ist halt so ein Ding, wo da fehlt mir halt jegliches Verständnis für. Oder auch irgendwie überhaupt dieses gesamte Thema nächtliche Ausgangssperre ist halt so ein Ding, wo einfach so jegliche Verhältnismäßigkeit verloren gegangen ist und einfach nur noch irgendwie so dieses irgendwie ach jetzt können wir endlich mal irgendwie so ein bisschen durchregieren. Hauptsache es fühlt sich möglichst hart und einschränkend an. Ding durchkam.
Nee, das ist aber Compliance. Das siehst du auch in großen Konzernen. Also kann ich vielleicht kurz aus den Nährkästchen erzählen. Ich war damals bei Microsoft in einem Gig, als Bill Gates das berühmte Memo rumschickte, dass er irgendwie Security wichtig finde und außer dem mag er XML. Und der gesamte Apparat in dieser Firma hat praktisch über Nacht angefangen, überall XML einzubauen. Ja, so ist das in großen Unternehmen. Wenn irgendwie der Chef sagt, XML ist geil, dann machen alle XML. Und wenn der Chef in Berlin sagt, hör mal zu, ohne Maske geht jetzt nicht mehr raus, dann gucken die, wo können wir denn am problemlosesten Leute finden, die ohne Maske rumlaufen? Und das sind die nachts. Genau wie, was habe ich neulich gelesen? Das kriege ich jetzt nicht mehr richtig zusammen, aber es ging irgendwie um Schüler. Genau. In Berlin ist es so, dass es ein kostenloses Schüler-BVG-Ticket gibt. Und worauf haben sich also die BVG-Kontrollierer spezialisiert? Auf Schüler, die ihr Ticket vergessen haben. Weil sie genau wissen, irgendwie jeder kann eins haben. Es ist absolut sinnlos, die zu verfolgen. Das kostet sogar nichts. Also jedes Kind, was es beantragt, kriegt es. Aber das ist dann halt mal zu Hause vergessen oder was weiß ich. Und in Berlin haben wir also das System, wir haben einmal die Busse und Bahn, das ist die BVG. Und dann haben wir die S-Bahn, das ist die Bahn. Die BVG ist so dann noch halbwegs freundlich, aber die S-Bahn hat gezielt ihren Kontrollettis gesagt, geht mal irgendwie Kinder rausgreifen, Schüler auf dem Weg von oder zur Schule. Und das ist genau dieselbe Scheiße, ja. Weil die Leute haben ja nicht den Auftrag, irgendwie sinnvolle Corona-Geschichten umzusetzen, sondern die haben den Auftrag, Schwarzfahrer zu erwischen. Und das ist halt ein leichtes Ziel.
Ja, aber das ist halt aus meiner Sicht genau das, was falsch ist an staatlicher Autorität.
Ja, natürlich. Klar läuft das falsch. Aber es ist nicht so, dass da irgendjemand einen Power-Trip hatte, sondern der wollte halt die Zahlen vorweisen.
Diese Ordnungsamt-Typen hatten definitiv einen Power-Trip. Also ohne jeglichen Zweifel. Und dass der Staat immer noch versucht, diese Strafen zu kassieren, ist einfach auch so ein Power-Trip-Ding. Es tut mir leid, das ist irgendwie...
Nee, die sind einfach Pleite. Hör mal, das kannst du doch einmal... Da bist du nur wirklich der Letzte, wenn ich das erklären muss. Wenn du siehst, wie das Finanzamt einfach Geld einzieht, wo sie genau wissen, dass du das wiederkriegst, wenn du Beschwerde einlegst, weil das Bullshit war, dann weißt du, dieser Staat ist Pleite und greift nach jedem Strohhalm. Auch Schwarzfahrer, natürlich. Oder Corona-Opfer. Ja, also ich hab gehört, in Berlin ist sogar noch relativ billig im Vergleich zu anderswo. Aber das weiß ich nicht aus persönlicher Erfahrung.
Ja gut, aber tatsächlich ist es halt so, dass die Erfahrung der unmittelbaren Begegnung mit dem Staat so führt eben auch dazu, dass sich zumindest mein, meine Sicht auf den Staat gravierend dramatisch verschlechtert hat. So, also ich muss einfach sagen, aus meiner Sicht ist der Staat in Berlin ist Quell eines größeren Teils meiner Frustration. So und das halt einfach so egal, ob es jetzt Steuern zahlen oder irgendwie diese Ordnungsamtsidioten sind. Das ist halt so ein Ding, was für mich dazu geführt hat zu sagen, weniger davon ist besser. So je weniger irgendwie diese Leute Macht haben, desto besser ist das. So und das vielleicht ein bisschen verkürzende Sicht, aber solange das halt nicht besser wird, solange der Staat mir gegenüber nicht freundlich und irgendwie sachlich agiert, will ich davon nicht noch mehr haben.
Das ist halt antagonistisch. Das fühlt sich nicht an wie jemand, der mit ihr Dinge erledigen will, sondern jemand, der gegen die Sachen durchsetzen will. Und das hätten sie einfach echt in der Hand, das zu ändern, aber sie tun es nicht. Wir haben hier noch die These, wir haben hier noch die These stehen auf unserer Vorbereitungsliste, dass der Staat eigentlich wollte, aber halt kaputtgespart wurde und deswegen sich das gar nicht kann. Woran würde man das festmachen? Wie erkennt man das?
Na gut, ich meine, das Gejammer, was halt immer kommt, dass kein Geld für dieses Realis da ist, weil es halt in den Budgets keinen Platz mehr dafür gibt, kann man ja aus zwei Richtungen identifizieren. Entweder heißt es, dass der Staat zu viele Aufgaben übernommen hat, also dass quasi die Liste der Dinge, die der Staat erledigen muss mit dem Geld, was er aus den Steuern kriegt, zu lang geworden ist, oder dass der Staat ineffizient ist, also dass quasi die Menge an Geld, die er dabei verbrennt, diese Aufgaben zu erfüllen, wenn halt einfach viel zu groß ist, daraus resultiert ja dann diese Public-Private-Partnership-Quatsch-Idee. Und dann kann man allerdings noch die dritte These wagen und sagen so, naja, letzten Endes ist die Frage, welche Aufgaben sollte denn so ein Staat tatsächlich erledigen und welche Machtmittel geben wir ihm dafür, muss halt eigentlich immer wieder diskutiert werden. Wo halt einfach so ein, dadurch dass halt aber inzwischen so viele Menschen abhängig vom Staat sind, irgendwie entweder, indem sie ihr Geld von dem beziehen oder weil der Staat irgendwie Geld kassiert von irgendwie Leuten, was sie dann bekommen oder weil sie halt irgendwie Fördertöpfe haben und so weiter und so fort. Ist halt so groß geworden, dass die Idee, dass man da mal vielleicht mal irgendwie eine sinnvolle, rationale Reform ansetzen könnte, die jetzt nicht das Ziel hat, irgendwie dass Dinge schlechter werden, sondern dass halt Dinge effizienter und zielgerichter da passieren. Da gibt es dann halt automatisch Widerstand, weil es dann jedes Mal sofort Kürzungen. Also dann hast du halt irgendwie die Leute, die halt Jugendarbeit machen, die sagen, wir kriegen keine Kohle mehr dafür, dass wir unsere Jugendarbeit machen, weil irgendwie die Budgets dafür gekürzt wurden. Und da hängen halt auch einfach Leute dran, die sich auf dieses Thema spezialisiert haben, die irgendwie die Ausbildung dafür haben, die darin qualifiziert sind und im Zweifel auch gute Arbeit machen und dann aber alle drei Jahre darum bangen müssen, dass ihre Institutionen halt weiter finanziert wird. Das sind ja immer so die Konflikte, die dann so ausgetragen werden. Und ich glaube, dass diese Parallelität von der Staat, sagt er, ist chronisch klamm und irgendwie er ist halt irgendwie unterfinanziert. Er kann sich keine guten Leute leisten und muss immer hier und da kürzen und sparen. Auf der einen Seite und auf der anderen Seite eine Staatsquote und eine Steuerquote, die halt so unglaublich hoch ist, weist halt darauf hin, dass es da ein systematisches Problem gibt. Also das halt...
Naja, also pass mal auf. Ich sehe, dass wie viel Kohle der Staat für McKinsey und die Bundeswehr hat. Ja, und das ist der Moment, wo ich mir sage, ach, weißt du, euer ganzes Gesölze von wegen, wir sind klamm, glaube ich doch nicht. Ja, so das ist das, wo ich sehe, wenn ich denke, ja, okay, meine Straßenlaterne könnt ihr nicht reparieren, aber irgendwie für eine Fregatte der Bundesmarine reicht es. So, nee, das kannst du nicht erklären. Ansonsten ist das doch der zu erwartende Zustand. Du hast auch immer ein Equilibrium. Die Ausgaben werden immer irgendwie gedeckelt und natürlich wird dann der Apparat alles Geld rausziehen, was da ist. Du wirst immer am Anschlag sein. Also, das kann gar nicht anders sein. Fast egal, wie du da die Anreize setzt. Daraus kannst du auch nichts schließen, dass es so ist.
Ich denke, dass es halt eine Kombination ist. Dass es halt irgendwie zum einen so ist, dass der Staat mit dem Geld, was er von uns kriegt, nicht besonders zielführend effizient umgeht. So, indem er halt irgendwie Subventionen an Großkonzerne schiebt, irgendwie sein Beschaffungswesen so strukturiert hat, dass es primär in deren Richtung fließt, sich halt nicht in der Lage sieht, seine Kernaufgaben in einer Art und Weise zu erledigen, die man als funktionsfähig wahrnimmt. Also diese Kombination weist halt eben darauf hin, dass man mal genau darüber reden muss, wofür geben wir unser Geld jetzt eigentlich geradeaus. Und da hast du dann halt natürlich aber halt eben die wohl organisierten großen Interessensträger, die mit Zähnen umklauen, dafür sorgen werden, dass halt irgendwie die Subventionen für Kohlekraftwerke nicht gestrichen werden, dass irgendwie die Subventionen für Flugwesen nicht gestrichen wird. Also warum haben wir immer noch keine Mehrwertsteuer auf Flugbenzin? Das ist halt so völlig unerklärbar. Das ist halt so ein Ding, wo man sagt so, wie jetzt. Und das sind halt, glaube ich, so Punkte, wo die, also diese Frustration darüber, dass halt der Staat zum einen so viel Kohle kassiert, aber zum anderen trotzdem so ineffizient ist, in den wahrnehmbaren Erfüllungen seiner Aufgaben, ist, glaube ich, so eine Sache, die so langsam jetzt so einen Knackpunkt erreicht. Ich bin mal sehr gespannt, ob jetzt da was passiert. Okay, ich hab nicht besonders viele Hoffnungen, weil jetzt der Aufbau von irgendwie noch mehr Förderung für irgendwie Klimawandel-Geschichten eher dazu führen wird, dass das Problem sich halt noch verschärft.
Naja, auf der anderen Seite hast du halt auch Zinszahlungen für die gewaltigen Kredite, die wir für uns als im Moment sind. Welche Zins? Im Moment haben wir gerade so den...
Der Bund kriegt gerade Geld dafür, dass er Geld verborgt.
Ja, aber das wird nicht so bleiben, da sind wir uns einig. Und das war auch noch nie so vor irgendwie jetz halt, ne? Aber im Wesentlichen ist es auch so, dass lange Jahre eins der Probleme für den Staat war, dass ein Großteil des Budgets, also der Teil, wo es überhaupt noch Handlungsfähigkeit gibt, der nicht schon durch Gesetze vergeben ist, zum Beispiel sozial und Bundeswehr, Etat und so Geschichten, da wo man da noch was machen konnte, das waren nur so was wie zehn Prozent vom Etat. Der Rest war schon vorgeschrieben. Das heißt, man guckt immer zu Politik und denkt irgendwie, ja, warum macht ihr denn nichts? Ja, das war auch einer der Gründe. Ja, aber du, du, du wolltest ja noch weitergehen mit der Staatsquote. Du meinst ja, der Staat ist damit auch zum Capture Ziel geworden.
Ja, definitiv.
Und kann sich auch gar nicht dagegen wehren, gecaptured zu werden. Erklär das doch mal, was ein Capture Ziel ist.
Naja, also Regulatory Capture funktioniert halt so, dass du staatliche Regulierung möglichst immer insbesondere in neuen Feldern zu deinen Gunsten beeinflusst. Und das kann halt viele verschiedene Formen haben. Eine davon ist...
Als Konzern jetzt?
Als Konzern, genau. So eine der Formen ist halt, dass man sagt, um irgendwie mehr soziale Gerechtigkeit, was auch immer, durchzusetzen müssen, irgendwie Beschaffungsaufträge nur an Firmen gehen, die versprechen, dass sie 100% carbon-neutral sind, sowas. Was dann halt wiederum bedeutet, dass du als Firma halt da nur mitspielen kannst, wenn du halt eine entsprechende Abteilung hast, die sich darum kümmert, zu erfassen, wie viel Carbon Footprint hab ich denn eigentlich, welche, was für Offset-Maßnahmen kann ich denn jetzt eigentlich kaufen, auch wenn die möglicherweise Bullshit sind, aber hauptsache sie sind regulatorisch zugelassen und so weiter. Das führt dann halt wiederum dazu, dass solche Aufträge dann halt eben nur noch an Großkonzerne gehen, die halt in diese entsprechende Compliance-Abteilung haben. Das ist halt so eine Methode. Die andere Methode ist halt viel direkter, wo man zum Beispiel für bestimmte Technologien, die halt nur in einem bestimmten großen Scale überhaupt möglich sind, die halt vorschreibt. Und man sagt halt also hier, du kannst halt als Unternehmen halt nur diese oder diese Technologie verwenden zur Erfüllung dieses Auftrags. Und ja, lustigerweise sind diese Technologien dann halt nur bei zwei Konkurrenten, die sich gegenseitig absprechen, halt irgendwie zu haben. Oder es werden halt irgendwie einfach auch Ziele gesetzt. Also die besten, so bei Regulatory Capture sind halt zum Beispiel so die Tabakkonzerne. Also da ging es halt dann um E-Zigaretten neulich und die haben dann halt irgendwie dafür gesorgt, dass die Besteuerung von Nikotin in E-Zigaretten jetzt genauso gehandhabt wird, wie die Besteuerung von normalen Tabakprodukten. Also wo halt offensichtlich klar ist, E-Zigaretten machen sehr viel weniger Schaden als normale Tabakprodukte. Das heißt also eigentlich sollten die nicht so hoch besteuert werden, aber die Tabakkonzerne haben dafür gesorgt und im zweiten Schritt haben sie dafür gesorgt, dass die die Zulassungsvorschriften für so irgendwie E-Zigarettenprodukte halt so hoch gedreht sind. Also insbesondere in Amiland ist jetzt der Fall. Dass nur noch quasi Großkonzerne, die halt irgendwie sich leisten können, halt diese ewigen Studien durchzuführen und so weiter und so fort, halt irgendwie überhaupt ihre Produkte in den Markt bringen können. Das war halt alles unter der Überschrift, ja, irgendwie Gesundheitsschutz und man weiß das ja alles nicht so genau und so weiter und so fort. Man hätte aber auch einfach sagen können, naja gut, es gibt halt irgendwie eine Liste von Inhaltsstoffen, die genehmigt ist und der Rest kann da halt nicht drin sein. Und ansonsten ist uns egal, wie groß die Firma ist. Das wäre der andere Regulierungsansatz gewesen, nämlich einfach nur den Markt zu regulieren und nicht sich da noch lauter Dinge reinzubauen, die dazu führen, dass am Ende wiederum nur Großkonzerne, denen in der Lage sind, die Bedingungen zu erfüllen. Das sieht man halt an allen Orten. Überall hast du halt genau dieses Problem, dass diese Konsolidierungen in staatsabhängigen Industrien kommen halt eben auch daher, dass es halt eben nur noch oberhalb einer bestimmten Größe möglich ist, dir da halt zwei Dutzend Anwälte zu halten, die dann halt eben für dich halt irgendwie deinen ganzen Regulierungskram irgendwie erledigen. Und das ist halt so eine Tendenz, die halt dazu führt, dass immer weniger große Konzerne und der Staat halt einen immer größeren Teil der Wirtschaft ausmachen.
Es gibt noch ein paar andere Aspekte an Regulatory Capture, zum Beispiel, dass die Regulierungsbehörden ja Experten brauchen, die ihnen helfen und die kriegen sie halt nur aus den großen Konzernen. Ja, das heißt, bei den Tabakdingern war das auch ein Riesenproblem. Da waren halt alle Experten, die es gab, waren halt alle irgendwie in der Tasche der Tabakkonzerne. Und die Behörde hat gar keine unabhängigen Leute gefunden. Und die drei, die es gab, die sind dann von den Tabakkonzernen wegen Befangenheit, weil es ja Aktivisten seien irgendwie rausgekickelt worden. Ansonsten ist die Bankindustrie noch ein Vorzeige, ein Regulatory Capture-Ding. Und man muss sich das so vorstellen, dass das hand in Hand arbeitet, die Behörde und die existierenden Banken. Also man stellt sich das zum Beispiel so vor, die Deutsche Bank geht zur BaFin und sagt, hör mal, wäre das nicht eine gute Anforderung zu sagen, dass die Bank irgendwie versichert sein muss, dass sie irgendwie so und so viel Ausfall kompensieren kann. Und dann sagt die BaFin, ja, das klingt gut, das ist ja genau, was wir hier machen sollen, dafür sorgen, dass der Markt irgendwie stabil ist und Banken nicht umfallen. Das machen wir mal so und dann kostet diese Versicherung halt so viel, dass Start-ups sich das nicht leisten können. Zum Beispiel so, das wäre ein Beispiel. Oder irgendwelche Arbeitsschutzmaßnahmen, also die Sachen, die die Konzerne, die existierenden Marktteilnehmer vorschlagen, sind alles Sachen, die die eh schon haben, die aber neue Marktteilnehmer erst teuer anschaffen könnten.
Oder die ihnen leichtfallen zu erfüllen. Also den Großkonzernen leichtfallen zu erfüllen.
Ja, aber jedenfalls führt es am Ende dazu, dass die Regulierungsbehörde am Ende das Gegenteil dessen tut, was sie eigentlich tun sollte, nämlich die existierenden Leute da im Saft halten und keine Konkurrenz ermöglichen. Und das führt dann eben dazu, dass bei uns keine einzige Bank wirklich zugemacht hat in der Bankenkrise. Weil dann im Zweifelsfall nämlich auch die Banken sagen können, ja hör mal, wenn wir hier pleite gehen, das kostet Arbeitsplätze. Das heißt, die Regulierungsbehörde hat dann auch Angst um ihren Einfluss, wenn es weniger Banken gibt, weil irgendwie welche davon umgefallen sind. Das heißt, der Effekt ist jedenfalls, dass die Regulierungsbehörde am Ende das Gegenteil dessen reguliert, was sie eigentlich tun sollte, nämlich da praktisch die bestehenden Verkrustungen noch zementiert.
Ja, gut.
Kommen wir zu Teil 2?
Ja, genau. Also eine der interessanten Fragen ist ja, auf welcher Basis sollte denn so Entscheidungen getroffen werden, die halt irgendwie gesellschaftlichen Trag weiter haben? Und was sind eigentlich so die Grundlagen, mit denen man quasi so eine Steuerung macht? So und es gibt ja so diese, so den kybernetischen Ansatz, der sagt, wir brauchen halt möglichst viele Daten und dann können wir diese Daten halt verarbeiten und dann wissen wir, was wir tun müssen.
Und mit Blockchain in der Cloud?
Naja, das mit dem Blockchain in der Cloud ist jetzt neuer, aber so der Kybernetik-Ansatz ist ja schon ein bisschen älter. Aber jedenfalls halt irgendwie eine möglichst, möglichst hohe Dichte an Planung ermöglichen. So und wie gut es funktioniert, sehen wir jetzt gerade irgendwie bei der Impfstoffversorgung so. Also wer hätte damit rechnen können, dass wenn man irgendwie wochenlang Propaganda in allen Medien fährt, dass sich alle impfen lassen sollen und gleichzeitig die boosterfristen ablaufen und die Leute sich boostern lassen wollen. Wer hätte irgendwie damit rechnen können, dass man jetzt plötzlich mehr Impfstoff braucht? Ich ist völlig überraschend. Also deswegen gibt es jetzt irgendwie auch wieder nicht genug Impfstoff für alle. Naja, jedenfalls das ist halt so ein typisches Beispiel für halt irgendwie so wie gut denn halt so Planung funktioniert auf der Basis von Modulierungen, die halt inkompetent sind. Und die Grundlage für Modulierungen sind ja so Statistiken und Wissenschaft. Und man versucht halt irgendwie daraus irgendwie so ein Gefühl dafür zu bekommen, in welche Richtung man steuern muss. Und wir haben halt festgestellt, dass sowohl in der Öffentlichkeit als auch irgendwie bei vielen Journalisten und irgendwie auch natürlich dementsprechend bei vielen Politikern jede Menge Probleme im grundlegenden Verständnis davon, wie man Wissenschaft und Statistik interpretiert, wahrhanden sind. Die halt dazu führen, dass an vielen Stellen einfach so ein Gefühl von Beliebigkeit entsteht, also dass es eigentlich ein bisschen egal ist, weil man halt irgendwie sich irgendwie immer rausreden kann, diese Statistik ist jetzt nicht relevant, weil dies oder jenes der Fall ist, oder diese Statistik ist jetzt relevant, weil sie mir gerade in den Kram passt. Und da wollten wir halt ein bisschen drauf eingehen, indem wir mal so ein bisschen iterieren durch die typischen Fehler, die man so machen kann bei der Interpretierung von Studien, von Wissenschaft, von Statistik.
Ja, das sind nicht alles so Fehler, die man die mit Studien zu tun haben. Es gibt auch ein paar grundlegende Probleme. Also viele Leute haben auch einfach in Mathe gepennt. Man muss einfach sagen, es geht schon mit Bruchrechnung los.
Bruchrechnung und Mengenlehre sind so schwierige Dinge.
Ja, ist eigentlich erstaunlich, denn Mengenlehre fand ich über den intuitivsten Teil an Mathe. So was irgendwie eine Teilmenge ist, das kannst du doch aufmalen und dann. Aber so viele Leute, wenn du die zum Beispiel fragst, ist ein Viertel oder ein Fünftel mehr? Da gibt es also einen signifikanten Teil, der glaubt, ein Fünftel ist mehr, weil die Fünf ist halt größer als vier. Und mit anderen Brüchen wird es noch schlimmer, wenn dann plötzlich irgendwie der Zähler und der Nenner verschieden sind. Also zum Beispiel so drei Fünfte oder fünf Achtel, was ist mehr? Da muss man dann auch irgendwie den Taschenrechner rausholen, ja, weil intuitiv hat man da häufig keinen Zugang.
Na gut, aber bei drei Fünfte und fünf Achtel liegen die Ergebnisse sehr nah beieinander. Das ist ja fast ein Rundungsfehler. Naja. Also drei Fünfte sind 60 Prozent, irgendwie fünf Achtel sind 62,5 Prozent, aber das ist...
Ja, deswegen hab ich die Zahlen ja auch so gewählt, damit das irgendwie nicht zu... Aber was ich sagen will ist, jedenfalls, wenn es auf der Ebene schon nicht passt, dann ist natürlich der Rest erst recht schwierig. Dazu kommt, dass einfach auch häufig Zahlen abstrakt sind und überhaupt nicht, man hat gar keinen intuitiven Zugang, ab einer gewissen Größe sowieso. Aber zum Beispiel so zehn Leute kann ich mir halt vorstellen, hundert Leute kann ich mir auch vorstellen. Und je weiter das darüber liegt, desto abstrakter ist das. Das heißt, wenn jetzt im Covid-News von irgendwie fünf Millionen infizierten Geräte ist oder von hunderttausend Toten, das sind im Grunde alle Leute völlig abstrakte Größen, wo man überhaupt keinen Zugang mehr zu hat. Ja, dann denkt man sich so, ja, halt viele. Aber halt viel kann ja heißen, okay, das ist schon eh viel, haben wir verloren. Oder viel kann auch heißen, oh, da sollten wir jetzt mal gegensteuern. Das heißt, wenn ich diese Art von Intuition nicht mehr habe, dann ist natürlich auch die Bewertung von sowas schwierig.
Ja, ich finde auch, dass man halt so diese Mengenangabe jetzt bei der Inzidenz so auf hunderttausend bezieht und dann halt auch noch im Sieben-Tages-Mittel zurückliegend, ist zwar wissenschaftlich korrekt, aber hilft halt eben nicht beim intuitiven Verständnis. Also das ist halt so ein, also wenn man da halt irgendwie, wahrscheinlich war halt so die Überlegung so, naja, also wenn wir das jetzt halt mal auf eins runterbrechen, also wenn wir jetzt halt sagen, wir nehmen jetzt mal nicht hunderttausend als Gesamtmenge, sondern irgendwie, wir sagen jetzt mal hundert, ja? Also dann klingt es möglicherweise dann halt irgendwie wenig so, weil man dann halt sagt, okay, die Wahrscheinlichkeit sich anzustecken, dass ein Infizierter dabei ist, ist halt so was wie einer von 200. Da denkt man sich so, naja, 200 Leute kann ich mir vorstellen, und das einer dabei, naja Gott, das ist jetzt nicht so tragisch. Also was jetzt irgendwie so was wie eine Inzidenz von 500 auf 100.000 wäre. Und das glaube ich auch so ein Problem, dass durch den Versuch, dass 500 sollte nach mehr klingen als irgendwie eins oder so, also dass man da halt irgendwie so eine ist aus dem Bereich des Vorstellbaren herauskaterpultiert hat.
Ich glaube, das war wie bei Celsius, dass sie gesagt haben, der Wertebereich soll zwischen 0 und 100 liegen. 100 ist schlimm, irgendwie 0 ist gut. Deswegen haben sie bei den, das ist ja relativ früh, irgendwie haben wir uns ja auf diese Einheit geeinigt. Und am Anfang war das ja wirklich so, dass die die Notbremse griff ab, was war das, 150? Und 100 war aber schon irgendwie, dass wir jetzt bei über 1000 sind, das ist natürlich doof, ja. Aber das ist ja im Grunde eine willkürliche Entscheidung, wie viel pro was man da guckt. Aber schon das pro 100.000 hat auch andere Probleme. Wir haben jetzt ja zum Beispiel immer Inzidenzen in irgendwelchen Landkreisen. Und jetzt stellt euch mal irgendein Landkreis in Mecklenburg-Vorpommern vor, da wohnen irgendwie nur 200 Leute. Also jetzt mal rein hypothetisch gesprochen. Und da sind jetzt irgendwie zwei von krank. Dann hast du dann eine Inzidenz, wenn du das auf 100.000 umrechnest, die fantastisch hoch ist, aber die Aussage ist sehr begrenzt. Das heißt, da muss man überhaupt immer gucken bei Statistiken. Ist überhaupt eine sinnvolle Aussage hinter dem Wert, den ich hier messe. So das Problem dabei eben tricksen kann mit dieser Abstraktheit und der fehlenden Intuition, indem man in solche Werte dann anfängt, absolute Zahlen reinzumixen. Also z.B. ein absoluter Wert, der im Moment umgereicht wird, ist Deutschland hat noch 2.000 Intensivbetten frei oder zweieinhalbtausend. Ist ja egal, wie viele es sind, aber das ist halt ein konkreter Wert und Betten kann man sich vorstellen. 2.000 ist zwar auch schon relativ abstrakt, aber da hab ich noch eine Vorstellung davon, wie viel das ist. Da kann ich mir vorstellen, wie ich einfach 2.000 Betten irgendwie in der Reihe stelle und dann langlaufe. Und das klingt halt nach viel. Oder ein anderer. Also wie gut das zum Steuern benutzt werden kann, habe ich mir überlegt, da habe ich ein schönes Beispiel gefunden. Die NATO möchte ja gern, dass Deutschland die Rüstungsaufgaben von 2% auf 4% steigern.
Nee, die wollen, dass wir überhaupt auf 2% kommen. Wir sind gerade bei 1,0 irgendwas.
Na ja, also langfristig wollten sie 4% haben. Das weiß ich noch, habe ich mir ausgeschnitten damals. Aber der Punkt ist jedenfalls, ob wir jetzt 1,5 oder 2 oder 4% sagen, das klingt wenig. Das heißt, die meisten Leute lesen es und denken so, ja, lass sie mal erzählen, interessiert doch nicht. Aber als Konkrast dazu, Milliardenbeträgen lesen. Ja, wir haben so und so 4 Milliarden, machen wir jetzt locker oder Millionen, machen wir jetzt locker für Quantencomputer oder was weiß ich. Da wird immer mit absoluten Zahlen gerechnet. Und wenn man dann mal guckt, wie viel Forschungsausgaben haben wir eigentlich in Prozent vom Gesamtetat, dann sind das nämlich unter 2. Das heißt, die Rüstungsausgaben und die Forschungsausgaben sind nicht so weit voneinander entfernt, wie man denken würde. Aber das ist ja nicht die Botschaft, die die Politik haben will. Die Politik möchte gern so tun, als würden wir viel in Forschung und wenig in Rüstung investieren. Und deswegen kriegen wir bei Rüstungsausgaben immer Prozentangaben. Aber das ist im Grunde ein Exploit gegen euch, weil ihr keine intuitiven Vorstellungen von großen Zahlen habt.
Ja, und dazu kommt dann natürlich noch irgendwie, weil wir gerade bei Intensivbetten waren, dass halt dieses sind noch 2000 Betten frei ist eine Übersimplifizierung. Also die gibt ja nicht die Realität wieder.
Ja, also das, wie gesagt, man muss gucken, ist der Messwert überhaupt sinnvoll. Aber was eben noch schlimmer ist, ist, wenn das Modell schon schlecht ist, die Annahme, das Annahmegerüst, auf dem man hier arbeitet. Also zum Beispiel ist bei Intensivbetten jetzt so, dass die Anzahl der Betten eigentlich egal ist, wichtig ist, wie viel Personal habe ich. Wir haben nämlich regelmäßig weniger Personal als wir brüchten, um die Betten zu bespielen. Das heißt, dass da Betten frei sind, liegt nicht daran, dass wir niemanden hätten, den wir da sinnvoll reinlegen könnten, sondern dass wir kein Personal haben. Und damit ist diese ganze Aussage, das Gerede über wie viel freie Intensivbetten wir haben, ist an sich schon sinnlos, wenn man das versteht. Und im Übrigen haben wir jetzt schon Absagen und Verschieben von planbaren OPs, damit wir noch Intensivbetten für absolute Ultra-Notfälle frei haben. Das heißt, die ist nicht mal unverfällt, die Statistik. Diese Art von Statistik macht vielleicht Sinn, wenn man sich so einen Wald anguckt, irgendwie wie sich da die, keine Ahnung, die Käfer irgendwie fortpflanzen. Aber nicht, wenn es einen Gegenspieler gibt, der mit Intentionen handelt.
Ja, also.
Und das ist halt hier der Fall.
Also in dem Fall sind die Gegenspieler halt die Klinikkonzerne, die halt nochmal völlig eigene Motivationen haben. Und halt, muss man auch einfach klar sagen, einfach das Personal halt irgendwie in den letzten zwei Jahren so dermaßen verschlissen haben, dass irgendwie die Anzahl der Leute, die in dem Bereich noch arbeiten wollen, obwohl sie dafür die Ausbildung haben, dramatisch gefallen ist.
Ja, das machen die auch nicht, weil sie gerne Leute sterben sehen wollen, sondern weil die als kommerzieller Profit-Center betrieben werden.
Genau.
Ja, man erwartet heutzutage von Krankenhäusern, dass die Gewinn abwerfen. Und dann guckt sich das Krankenhaushalt an. Was ist hier die größte Kostensenke? Und das sind halt Intensivbetten, die ungenutzt sind. Ja, und das heißt, dass die Krankenhäuser schon vor der Pandemie alle ihre Intensivbetten genau so viel im Bestand hatten, wie man halt sinnvoll füllen kann im Normalbetrieb. Und vielleicht noch ein oder zwei für irgendwie, falls irgendwo ein Auffahrunfall auf der Autobahn ist oder so. Aber nicht deutlich mehr. Und Deutschland ist noch ganz vorne im Übrigen dazu, zur Anzahl der Intensivbetten pro 100.000 Bevölkerung.
Ja, jetzt hat man natürlich diese Gesamtverzerrung mit der Gesundheitskostenstruktur, die halt eben durch diese Profikalkulationen kommt, führt jetzt eben auch dazu, dass es halt irgendwie kaum noch möglich ist, da halt sinnvoll zu steuern. Also wenn es irgendein Gebiet gibt, in dem eine sinnvolle Meta-Steuerung kaum möglich ist, dann ist es in Deutschland halt das Gesundheitswesen. Weil zum einen gibt es halt sehr viele Player, die halt irgendwie alle ihre eigenen Profitinteressen haben. Und zum anderen ist halt so, dass die, sagen wir mal, die Ausbeutung des medizinischen Personals wird da halt einfach so dermaßen als gegeben genommen. Das sind halt irgendwie Idealisten, die arbeiten halt da und die kann man halt so weit ausquetschen, bis sie halt im Zweifel gehen. Das ist halt so eine Systematik, die wäre uns früher oder später sowieso auf die Füße gefallen und jetzt irgendwie mit Corona wird das halt massiv beschleunigt.
Ja, die ist uns auch vorher schon auf die Füße gefallen. Das hat nur keiner sehen wollen. Also der Pflegestreik ist seit Jahren ein Thema. Aber das ignoriert man halt, solange man nicht krank ist. Und da sind wir völlig selber schuld. Es ist auch nicht so, dass die Krankenhäuser alle die fetten Gewinne abwerfen. Also die Privatisierung, die waren teilweise hoch verschuldet. Und jetzt die haben noch mal massiv zusätzliche Einsparungen gemacht, die Käufer von den Krankenhäusern. Das heißt, wenn jetzt jemand kommt und sagt, okay, wir müssen das reformieren, wir müssen hier mehr Intensivbetten vorhalten und wir müssen die Pfleger ordentlich bezahlen, dann sagen die Krankenhausbetreiber, ja, dann gehen wir pleite. Und dann habt ihr gar keine Versorgung mehr. So, das heißt, man hat auch den Hebel gar nicht, da irgendwelche Vorschriften zu machen.
Na gut, ich meine, in gewisser Art und Weise schon, weil irgendwie die, also ich meine jetzt der letzte Streik in Berlin des Pflegepersonals, da ging es ja nicht darum, dass die mehr Geld wollten, sondern es ging nur darum, dass die wollten, dass die Personalschlüssel eingehalten werden. Also nur eingehalten werden.
Ja, das war auch mal richtig krass.
Also es ging wirklich nur darum, dass die gesagt haben, wir wollen pro Patienten so und so viel Pflegepersonalschlüssel, der halt vorgeschrieben ist, eigentlich, dass der halt eingehalten wird. Das fand ich schon irgendwie einigermaßen übel.
Bitte halten sie sich auch bei uns an geltende Gesetze.
Genau.
Gut, aber eigentlich geht es uns gar nicht so ums Gesundheitssystem. Das soll nur als Beispiel dienen. Eigentlich geht es in der Sektion um den Umgang mit Wahrscheinlichkeiten und großen Zahlen. Und es stellt sich raus, das ist auch gar nicht so einfach, das zu lernen, weil viele Leute begegnen so Wahrscheinlichkeitsberechnungen in der Praxis gar nicht direkt, sondern indirekt irgendwie über Versicherungen oder so. Aber die zeigen dir ja nicht die Berechnungen, die dazu geführt hat, sondern das Ergebnis. Es wird immer teurer. Tatsächlich direkten Kontakt zu Wahrscheinlichkeiten hat man in Videospielen z.B. Und es stellt sich heraus, dass die Videospiele angefangen haben, den User zu bescheißen an der Stelle. Und zwar war es so, z.B. gab es eine schöne Story Sid Meier, der ist bekannt für die Civilization-Reihe von Spielen. Und da ist also so, wenn man von einem Feld aus mit seiner Armee ein benachbartes Feld angreifen will, dann sagt einem das Spiel, du hast jetzt eine Wahrscheinlichkeit von ein Drittel, dass es erfolgreich ist. Ja, so und was dann passiert ist, ist, dass der Spieler halt dreimal versucht hat. Und wenn die alle drei gescheitert sind, dann ist der Spieler halt sauer gewesen, weil er gesagt hat, wieso, da stand auch ein Drittel. Und ich habe dreimal probiert. Und das ist halt ein fundamentales Unverständnis von Wahrscheinlichkeiten. Aber das Ergebnis war, dass die das Spiel jetzt geändert haben. Wenn das vorher gesagt hat, ein Drittel und du probierst dreimal, dann gewinnst du beim dritten Mal automatisch, wenn die davor gescheitert. Das heißt, das Fehlverständnis wird sogar noch verstärkt durch Videospiele. Ich habe das hier mal aufgeschrieben, was denn tatsächlich die Wahrscheinlichkeitsverteilung ist. Wenn du ein Drittel Erfolgswahrscheinlichkeit hast und die Events unabhängig voneinander sind, hast du das erste Mal natürlich ein Drittel. Beim zweiten Mal, dass du beide Male getroffen hast, wäre dann ein Drittel vom Drittel. Und dreimal treffen, wäre halt nur noch 3,7 Prozent. Aber eigentlich geht es ja ums Nichttreffen. Und das ist halt auch nicht viel intuitiver. Das erste Mal nicht zu treffen hat Wahrscheinlichkeit von zwei Drittel, also 66 Prozent, dass du dann beim zweiten Mal auch nicht triffst, sind 44 Prozent. Und dass du dreimal in Reihe nicht triffst, sind immer noch ungefähr 30 Prozent Wahrscheinlichkeit. Das heißt, die Annahme, dass du bei einer Wahrscheinlichkeit von einem Drittel einfach dreimal probierst, und dann muss es geklappt haben. Die ist halt falsch. Und zwar richtig doll falsch, ja. Das war jetzt das eine bekannte Beispiel. Es gab noch ein anderes Schönes. Da ging es um so einen taktischen Shooter, XCOM. Da muss man irgendwie Aliens bekämpfen. Und der zeigt dir halt an, wenn du so sagst, ich überlege, ob ich jetzt hier hinschießen soll, sagt er so was wie 85 Prozent Trefferwahrscheinlichkeit. Ja, und dann haben die Leute 85 Prozent gesehen und sind sauer geworden, wenn sie nicht getroffen haben. Weil die gucken halt 85 Prozent an und denken sich ja, das heißt doch sicher treffen. Heißt es halt nicht. 85 Prozent heißt 15 Prozent Wahrscheinlichkeit, dass du nicht triffst. Und weil das Wahrscheinlichkeiten sind, wenn du das zweimal probierst, kannst du auch zweimal nicht treffen. Das ist halt nicht sehr wahrscheinlich, aber es kann halt passieren. So und dann haben die Spiele-Fährsteller gesagt, ja wir wollen ja hier die Leute unterhalten und nicht frustrieren. Und dann haben die halt angefangen, da falsche Wahrscheinlichkeiten anzuzeigen. Das heißt, wenn die 85 Prozent anzeigen, dann ist es eher so 95 Prozent, dass du triffst. Weil die einfach keinen Bock hatten, dass die genervten Kunden da Tickets aufgemacht haben. Und das heißt halt, dass wir auch eine Generation gerade heranziehen, die noch schlechter mit Wahrscheinlichkeitsrechnungen umgehen können als wir. Und wir sind schon schlechter.
Na super.
Das ist ja ganz toll.
Das heißt also, wir schaffen durch simulierte Realität eine verzerrte Wahrnehmung der echten Realität.
Genau. Und das kann man ja auch beobachten schon. Also es gibt zum Beispiel einen besonders, gibt einen Effekt, der ist besonders krass, wenn man da mal anfängt, drauf zu achten, sieht man den echt überall. Der heißt Post-Hog Ergo Pop-Dog. Das ist Latein und heißt danach, deswegen, danach, also deswegen. Das heißt, man sieht irgendwie Sache A passiert, dann passiert Sache B und dann nimmt man an, das wird schon wegen Sache A passiert sein, weil es in einem zeitlichen Verhältnis zueinander steht.
Also eine wahrgenommene Korrelation.
Ja, ich habe Globuli genommen, danach ging es mir besser, das wären die Globuli gewesen sein. Und das ist ja auch nachvollziehbar, der Gedankengang, bis man versteht, dass die Selbstheilungsquote irgendwie so was wie 75 Prozent sind bei Menschen. Also jetzt nicht bei allen Krankheiten, aber über alle Krankheiten gemittelt. Das heißt, in drei Viertel der Fälle geht es von alleine weg, auch ob du jetzt Globuli nimmst oder nicht. Das heißt, wenn du jetzt einfach messen möchtest, ob Globuli wirken, wirst du in drei Viertel der Fälle feststellen, es gab eine Wirkung. Und das ist natürlich für Menschen dann anzunehmen, nach einer Weile, dass es die Globuli gewesen sein wird. Ja, aber das ist natürlich Unsinn. Das muss man anders beweisen.
Wobei natürlich bei Globuli muss man natürlich dann noch dazu rechnen, dass da ist ja dann nicht nur die Selbstzahlungsquote im Spiel, sondern auch der Placebo-Effekt.
Genau, das kommt noch dazu. Aber selbst dafür gibt es Mittel und Wege, wie man eine Studie aufsetzen kann, um das rauszufinden, ob man hier gerade ein Placebo-Effekt misst oder überhaupt ein Effekt misst. Aber dieser Effekt ist so wichtig, dass ich mir gleich mehrere Beispiele überlegt hab. Ein anderes Ding wäre zum Beispiel, wir haben Geimpfte im Krankenhaus, also war die Impfung schlecht. Das ist natürlich genauso Blödsinn. Nur weil das in zeitlicher Nähe passiert ist, heißt das nicht, dass es miteinander zu tun hat. Oder die Impfnebenwirkungen. Das ist sogar noch ein bisschen krasser, weil das sind ja einfach nur Meldungen. Da wird ja nichts geprüft in den meisten Fällen. Also wenn jetzt jemand sagt, ich habe hier eine Hauptrötung, dann kommt das in eine Datenbank und da steht dann am Ende so was wie zweieinhalb Millionen Fälle von Nebenwirkungen sind gemeldet worden in den USA. Dann guckst du dir die an und das sind einfach Leute, die gesagt haben, ich habe so ein leichtes Jucken gehabt oder ich habe irgendwie einen rauen Hals gehabt oder ich hatte Haarausfall und es gibt also sehr wenig Indizien dafür, dass es irgendeine Korrelation auch nur gibt, sondern es ist halt irgendwie in zeitlicher Nähe passiert. Das muss nichts miteinander zu tun haben.
Und je größer halt die Grundgesamtheit ist, desto wahrscheinlich erwurzt halt, dass halt irgendwas passiert.
Ja, das ist eine richtig große Falle, deswegen reite ich da so drauf rum, auch unabhängig von Krankheiten, also zum Beispiel besonders häufig betroffen sind so Politiker oder Entscheider in Firmen, die irgendeine Aktion machen und dann bewerten wollen, ob die Aktion geholfen hat. Ja, da liegt es total nahe, einfach anzunehmen, das hat geholfen, weil eine Besserung eintrat. Aber die Besserung kann auch eingetreten sein, weil irgendein Nerd im Keller irgendwie unzufrieden war und gesehen hat, das Kabel saß nicht richtig und hat es halt gefixt. Also es ist immer sehr einfach und sehr intuitiv dann anzunehmen, dass meine Änderung etwas bewirkt hat oder meine Maßnahme und das ist eine der Gründe, warum die Politik mit diesen bekloppten Maßnahmen weitergemacht hat. Ja, es ist ja nicht so, dass die Leute erst angefangen haben, Masken zu tragen, als die Regierung gesagt hat, ihr müsst jetzt Masken tragen, sondern das gab es vorher schon. Das heißt, die Idee, dass die Regierung sieht, wir haben hier diese und jene Maßnahme verhängt und es ist besser geworden, das muss mit den Maßnahmen nichts zu tun haben. Also das nimmt die natürlich an die Regierung, weil die möchte ja gern helfen. Also das möchte ich auch gern mal mit aufräumen, mit der Idee, dass die Regierung irgendwie böse ist und Leute umbringen will. Die Regierung möchte, dass ihr weiter lebt, damit ihr Steuern zahlen könnt. Also die wollen euch nicht umbringen, im Gegenteil, die möchten gern, dass ihr alt werdet und Steuern zahlt, aber nicht so alt, dass ihr das Gesundheitssystem platt macht oder gar Rente braucht. Oder Rente braucht, genau, aber ihr solltet das Rentenalter selbst schon noch erleben. Dann könnt ihr gerne umkippen, aber bis dahin solltet ihr mit Steuern zahlen. Das heißt aber, nehmen wir mal an, du bist die Regierung und du verhängst irgendwelche Covid-Maßnahmen und dann kommen Frühling und Sommer, wo wir vorher wussten, dass die Corona-Viren dann sehr viel weniger aktiv sind und sehr viel weniger Probleme machen.
Beziehungsweise Leute sich weniger in den Räumen aufenthalten. Das ist ja der wesentliche Effekt. Also Frühling und Sommer ist ja nicht nur, dass die Ansteckungswahrscheinlichkeit insgesamt geringer ist, sondern dass die Anzahl der Situationen, an denen man sich anstecken kann, geringer ist, weil die Leute halt draußen sind.
Ja, also jedenfalls, dass die Welle praktisch von alleine aufhören wird, wenn wir jetzt Sommer haben, das war klar. Genauso wie klar war, dass es wieder losgeht, wenn wieder Herbst und Winter kommen. Aber jetzt stellt euch ein Politiker vor, der hat irgendwelche Covid-Maßnahmen verhängt und dann kommt der Sommer und Covid ist weg. Dann denke ich doch, boah, ich bin ja so gut. Meine Maßnahmen haben Covid ausgerottet. Und dann kommt Herr Söder im Herbst und sagt, also da konnte ja keiner mitrechnen, dass es jetzt wieder so schlimm wird. So wir hatten das doch besiegt. Also das ist eine total wichtige Fehlschlussfolgerung des Gehirns. Diese Idee, dass man irgendwie nur weil man Sachen in nähe, zeitlicher Nähe beobachtet, dass das eine des anderen ausgelöst haben wird. Da müsst ihr echt drauf achten.
Ja und dazu kommt natürlich eben das in dem Umblick, wo man halt ein reales oder politisches Kapital investiert hat in sowas. Dann kommen ja halt noch die psychologischen Faktoren dazu. Also dieses ganze, wenn ich jetzt schon so viel Geld oder politisches Kapital in etwas investiert habe, dann möchte ich halt irgendwie auch erstmal bei dieser Ansicht bleiben, weil sonst wird es ja irgendwie in den Talkshows dann als Flip-Flopping oder als irgendwie hart nicht durchgehalten irgendwie interpretiert. Was ja manchmal tatsächlich der Fall ist. Manchmal muss man Dinge ja auch länger tun, damit sie irgendwie wirklich funktionieren, aber trotzdem kann man da halt dieses dieses ganze Sunk and Cost Fallacy Problem halt irgendwie in der Regel nicht vermeiden.
Ja, also jetzt kommen wir in die psychologischen Faktoren, die eine Rolle spielen beim Entscheidenden selbst und beim Bewerten von Entscheidungen. Und da gibt es also so einen ganzen Komplex. Der Kahnemann hat da ein Buch geschrieben, das haben wir ja schon ein paar Mal angepriesen. Auf den gehen auch die Theorien der Loss Aversion und der Prospect Theory zurück. Und da geht es halt darum, zu gucken, wie Leute tatsächlich reagieren, wenn sie irgendwie eine Wahl haben zwischen zwei Optionen. Die Wissenschaft ist vorher immer davon ausgegangen, zu sagen, es gibt den sogenannten Homo economicus, der ist perfekt informiert und der handelt rational. Das heißt, wenn du zum Beispiel eine Versicherung anbietest und die Eintrittswahrscheinlichkeit ist irgendwie 1% und die zahlt 1000 Euro aus und die Polise kostet irgendwie 20 Euro, dann kommt der Homo economicus rechnet aus, irgendwie Eintrittswahrscheinlichkeit mal Schaden und wie viel er in der Zeit für die Polise zahlen würde und sagt, es lohnt sich nicht, aber so funktioniert der Mensch eben nicht. Der Mensch guckt sich das an und sieht die 1000 Euro Verlust, wenn er nicht versichert ist und denkt sich, oh, das sollte ich lieber versichern. Und diese Beobachtungen anzugucken, was die Leute tatsächlich machen, das hat eben der Kahnemann vorangetrieben und hat einige echt interessante Sachen gefunden. Zum Beispiel hat er herausgefunden, dass Menschen einen Gewinn deutlich weniger emotional spüren wie einen Verlust. Das heißt, wenn dir jemand eine Problematik so darstellt, als wenn du entweder viel oder wenig gewinnst, dann ist es völlig anders, als wenn jemand sagt, hier hast du 1000 Euro und jetzt haben wir eine Auswahl, ob du viel oder wenig verlierst. Was im Grunde der selbe Effekt ist unterm Strich. Aber die Leute sehen das anders, weil sie einen möglichen Verlust viel schlimmer betrachten als einen möglichen Gewinn. Das führt eben in der Werbung zu Sachen, die ausgenutzt werden. Zum Beispiel habt ihr vielleicht schon mal gesehen, der Media Markt hat so eine Aktion gehabt, wir zahlen die Mehrwertsteuer. Die Mehrwertsteuer wäre ein Verlust, der wird also höher bewertet als der Gewinn. Deswegen sagt hier nicht irgendwie, kost weniger, sondern sagt, wir zahlen die Mehrwertsteuer. Das war zum Beispiel eine Ausnutzung von diesem Ding. Oder wenn du sowas hast wie eine Probeperiode. Prospect Theory ist die Verallgemeinerung davon. Die sagen halt, okay, bei Menschen sind bei Gewinnen risikoaverse. Also das heißt, die möchten lieber kein Risiko eingehen. Wenn du zum Beispiel sowas hast wie Option 1, du kriegst 50 Euro. Option 2, du kriegst entweder 100 Euro oder gar nichts. Beides gleich wahrscheinlich. Dann ist das ja identisch für den Homo economicus.
Ist also dieses, lieber den Spatz in der Hand als die Taube auf dem Dach.
Und der Mensch guckt sich das an und sagt, 50 Euro nehme ich doch 50 Euro sicher, die nehme ich. Obwohl das dasselbe ist. Aber du siehst halt, wenn du die Leute beobachtest und nicht den Homo economicus, sondern was tatsächlich die Menschen da draußen tun, siehst du halt diese Art von Bias. Und wenn du das umformulierst und sagst, du musst entweder 50 Euro zahlen oder du musst zwischen 100 oder 0 Euro zahlen, dann sind die Leute plötzlich bereit und wollen das Risiko eingehen, weil es da eben das mögliche Outcome gibt, dass sie gar nichts zahlen müssen. Ja, und das heißt eben, dass wenn ihr eine Statistik ansieht, dass ihr gucken müsst, wie rum ist das formuliert. Falle ich da gerade auf diesen Bias rein. Also der ganze Komplex ist hochspannend. Die haben doch ein paar andere Sachen rausgefunden, zum Beispiel, dass am Ende des Spektrums, entweder bei sehr unwahrscheinlich oder sehr wahrscheinlich, gibt es noch eine Verzerrung. Aber man kann es auf Impfen anwenden. Zum Beispiel, überlegt euch mal, man kann es formulieren, die Impfung ist die Wahl zwischen entweder einer Krankheit, die ich möglicherweise kriege oder eine Impfung, die ich mir selber sozusagen zufüge, die also sicher ist. Und ich habe ja gerade erklärt, bei Verlusten ist es so, dass der Mensch dann lieber zockt, weil er sagt, okay, die Krankheit ist ja gar nicht klar, ob ich die wirklich kriege. Und das ist auch genau die Argumentation, die man von den Impfverweigerern gekriegt hat, dass sie gesagt haben, die Krankheit weiß ich ja gar nicht, ob ich mich wirklich anstecke.
Oder ob es bei mir so schlimm wird.
Genau. Und das ist genau diese Theorie live beobachtet. Das ist so einer der bekannten und wichtigen Biases an der Stelle.
Ich glaube, dass da auch dieses nicht richtig einschätzende von eigenen Wahrscheinlichkeiten, was das eigene Risiko angeht, das hat man ja so ein bisschen gesehen, dass die in der öffentlichen Propaganda dann halt so ein bisschen dagegen gesteuert wurden. Also dass man halt dann gesagt hat, so jetzt wird sich jeder anstecken, ist er denn erst geimpft. Das war ja quasi der Versuch, dem gegenzusteuern. Also die Wahrscheinlichkeit, dass du dich ansteckst, nähert sich jetzt so langsam den 100 Prozent. Das heißt, du kannst diese Kalkulation halt nicht mehr machen, war ja eben der Versuch, da halt kommunikativ gegenzusteuern.
Ja, das habe ich auch im Blog gemacht. Ich habe gesagt, geh mal davon aus, dass wir alle uns irgendwann anstecken werden und deine Wahl ist jetzt, ob du dann geimpft bist oder nicht. Und wenn du geimpft bist, hast du weniger Schaden. Ja, und damit wäre das sozusagen genau umgekehrt formuliert und damit ist auch eigentlich für die meisten Leute klar. Also das war sozusagen auch Ausnutzung der Prospect-DVD. Das habe ich aber natürlich nicht absichtlich gemacht, sondern weil das so meine Herleitung war. Ja, aber es kommt halt dazu, dass die Leute auch schlechteren sind, ihre eigenen Fähigkeiten einzuschätzen. Also das kannst du schon ganz klar, wenn du irgendwie 100 Leute fragst, ob sie sich für über- oder unterdurchschnittlich gute Autofahrer halten, dann werden die halt, wie so was wie 80 Prozent sagen, dass sie überdurchschnittlich gut sind. Ja, alle Leute halten sich für besser, als sie sind. Das ist irgendwie, ist halt so. Und das heißt aber auch, zum Beispiel, dass alle Leute glauben, ihr Immunsystem sei schon stark genug, wenn sie da nicht krasse Gegenbeispiele oder Beweise in der Hand haben. Dann nehmen erst mal alle an, ihr Immunsystem sei schon stark genug und da lege ich gar keine echte Gefahr vor. Aber das ist genauso blöd sind, wie anzunehmen, man sei ein besserer Autofahrer als der Durchschnitt.
Oder dass eine Regierung sagt, wir kommen mit diesen oder jenen Waschi-Waschi-Maßnahmen durch. Die werden uns schon helfen. Das ist ja auch so ein Optimismus.
Ja, die haben ja auch Messwerte in die Richtung. Das ist ja das Lustige. Der Messwert von der Regierung ist halt nicht, ob ihre bisherigen Maßnahmen funktioniert haben, sondern der Messwert ist, dass sie gewählt wurden. Und daraus folgt für die, dann werde ich wohl besonders kompetent sein, sonst hätten die mich ja nicht gewählt. Ein bisschen verwandt an der Stelle ist der Daniel Krüger-Effekt. Den haben wir auch schon ein paar Mal gehabt. Der sagt, dass je weniger du von einem Thema weißt, desto eher wirst du deine Fähigkeiten überschätzen. Es stellt sich nämlich raus, das Wissen, das man braucht, um zu erkennen, dass man keine Ahnung hat, das Wissen, das man gebraucht hätte, um die Ahnung zu haben. Das heißt, wenn du das nicht hast, dann weißt du halt nicht, dass du doof bist.
Und dann selektierst du halt im Zweifel auch deine Input-Quellen. Also dann sagst du halt irgendwie, ich habe jetzt halt irgendwie ein Weltbild und ich nehme jetzt nur noch oder bevorzugt die Fakten oder die Statistiken oder die umfragen war, die dieses Weltbild halt verstärken. Weil sonst müsste ich mich ja...
Ja, das haben wir nachher noch. Das ist ja Confirmation byes.
Naja, das ist halt eher Dissonanzvermeidung. Also dass man halt irgendwie versucht, sich möglichst nicht mit Sachen zu beschäftigen, die es erfordern würden, dass man seine Meinung ändert. Also dass man halt irgendwie nicht versucht, sich möglichst objektiv und umfassend zu informieren, sondern halt bei dem bleibt, wo man halt ist. Und da gab es dieses Jahr eine interessante Studie, die tun wir auch nochmal in die Show Notes. Die war so ein bisschen für mich die deprimierende Studie, nämlich sie haben halt untersucht, in welchen Einfluss das Maß an sozialer Interconnectedness, also mit wie viel Menschen man quasi kommuniziert, welchen Einfluss das darauf hat, ob man eher sich in seiner Meinung einbunkert oder eher ein bisschen weltoffener oder willens ist, seine Meinung zu ändern. Da stellt sich halt raus, dass es offenbar eine Obergrenze gibt. Das heißt also, dass die auch bei jedem Menschen unterschiedlich ist, abhängig von der sozialen Situation, dass je sicherer man sich in seiner sozialen Umgebung fühlt, desto eher ist man in der Willens, sich mit anderen Meinungen auseinanderzusetzen, weil man quasi nicht so viel zu verlieren hat. Aber in dem Augenblick, wo dieses Maß an Interconnectness, diese Maßzahl, die für jeden unterschiedlich ist, überschreitet, stellt sich eher so ein Einbunkerungseffekt ein. Also eher so ein bisschen zur Radikalisierung.
Der Facebook-Effekt.
Ja, das ist halt insofern dramatisch, weil wir bisher angenommen hatten so, okay, Filterbubbles sind schlecht. Und je mehr ich mich mit vielen verschiedenen Meinungen auseinandersetze, desto besser wird meine Weltsicht und desto objektiver wird die. Aber es stellt sich dann halt raus, dass in dem Augenblick, wo man dieses Maß überschreitet, desto wahrscheinlicher ist es, dass ich mich eher radikalisiere oder mich in der Meinung festfresse und andere Meinungen oder andere Ansichten oder auch andere Fakten umso stärker ablehne. Und das ist halt insofern deprimierend, weil es halt quasi diese Grundthese von so dem Internet als globalen Dorf, der es halt möglich macht, den objektiven Erkenntnisgewinn zu steigern, tatsächlich leider ad absurdum führt. Und wir halt irgendwie jetzt eher darüber nachdenken müssen, wie wir halt irgendwie Diskursräume schaffen, in denen wir die Möglichkeit haben, in einer sicher empfundenen Umgebung tatsächlich mich mit der Anzahl Leute auszutauschen, die für mich okay ist, wo ich also jetzt nicht die ganze Zeit halt irgendwie mich damit auseinandersetzen muss, dass ich halt von lauter Meinung bombardiert werde, die mich halt verunsichern und die dann halt eher dazu führen, dass ich halt irgendwie mich irgendwie in dem, was ich jetzt schon habe, also wo ich dann auch Zeit investiert habe, also ich sage ein Cost-Fallacy, mich dann halt irgendwie daran festklammere, weil ich halt eben auch so viel da investiert habe, den Effekt hat man ja dann auch bei so den diversen Spielarten halt irgendwie Die von esoterischen oder sonstigen Corona-Leugnern, die dann halt sagen, ich hab jetzt schon so viel Zeit mit YouTube und Googlen verbracht und bin mir absolut sicher, dass es meine richtige Meinung ist und dass ich jetzt die ganze Zeit in der Tagesschau mit irgendwie Gegeninformationen dazu bombardiert wäre, ist halt scheiße und das will ich halt nicht. Das ist halt eine ziemlich, ziemlich deprimierende Studie leider.
Ich finde das aber auch zum Teil zumindest intuitiv. Also ich kann das bei mir selbst beobachten. Je mehr Leute du in deinem direkten Umfeld hast, desto weniger Zeit hast du pro Person. Und das führt ja automatisch dazu, dass du pro Person halt auch weniger Zeit hast, dich tatsächlich damit auseinanderzusetzen, was die eigentlich sagen. Und dann kannst du nur noch oberflächlich rangehen. Ja, und das muss ja sozusagen dazu führen, dass du dann halt Kommunikationsprobleme hast. Was ich an der Distanzvermeidung krass finde, ist, dass das auch dazu führen kann, dass man praktisch sich selbst in Widersprüche verzettelt, ohne das zu merken. Also man sieht zum Beispiel gerne, dass Leute Regierungsstatistiken zitieren, bis die ihnen nicht in den Kram passen. Also dann kommen plötzlich Argumente wie ja, das ist die Regierung, die lügt ja eh. Das hat ihn aber nicht davor abgehalten, vorher diese anderen fünf Statistiken von der Regierung zu erzählen. Das heißt, die Argumente, die dann gebracht werden, die sind halt nicht tatsächlich Argumente, sonst hätten sie ja bei den anderen Instanzen auch gegolten, sondern das sind halt eher so vorgeschobene Geschichten. Aber das merkt man selber halt nicht. Wir sind auch selber betroffen. Also ich erzähl das jetzt hier, als wenn mich das alles nicht betrifft. Ich bin da natürlich genauso betroffen wie alle anderen auch. Aber es hilft, glaube ich, wenn man sich da so ein bisschen versucht, das praktisch gelegentlich immer mal so vorbeiscrollen zu lassen, damit man es nicht aus dem Auge verliert, dass diese Probleme gibt.
Ja.
Und dann gibt es noch Probleme mit Teilmengen. Das war jetzt bei der Impfdebatte so ein bisschen ein Problem, weil die Leute angefangen haben zu argumentieren, ja, aber im Krankenhaus sind ja immer mehr Geimpfte. Und das ist einfach ein Problem daher, dass die Wahrscheinlichkeiten ja relative Angaben sind, keine absoluten. Das heißt, wenn ich sozusagen Menge A habe und da ist die Infektionswahrscheinlichkeit 10 Prozent und ich habe Menge B und da ist sie 1 Prozent, dann würdest du davon ausgehen, dass von Menge A viel mehr Leute krank werden, weil die Wahrscheinlichkeit zehnmal so hoch ist. Aber das heißt nicht, dass es auch tatsächlich so ist. Das wäre nur so, wenn die auch ungefähr gleich groß sind. Wenn aber die Menge, die mit der geringeren Wahrscheinlichkeit zehnmal so groß ist, dann wäre der Effekt wieder weg. Und je mehr Leute wir impfen, desto höher wird der Anteil der Geimpften in den Krankenhäusern sein. Das muss so sein. Das ist praktisch eine mathematische Sicherheit. Da gibt es ein schönes Experiment für von wieder von Kahnemann, die Conjunction Fallacy heißt das. Er hat hier so eine schöne Story, dass Leute mit Teilenmengen Probleme haben. Da erzählt er so was wie, das ist Linda, sie ist 31 Jahre alt, sie ist ein Single, sie redet viel und gerne, ist extrovertiert, ist sehr schlau, hat Philosophie studiert und sie war auch immer sich in Diskriminierung und Social Justice bemüht im Studium und hat bei Anti-Atom-Demonstrationen teilgenommen. Und dann ist die Frage, was ist wahrscheinlicher? Sie ist Bankangestellte oder sie ist Bankangestellte und aktive Feministin? Und dann werden die meisten Leute sagen, sie ist Bankangestellte und aktive Feministin, obwohl das ja per Definition eine Teilmenge davon ist, dass sie bloß eine Bankangestellte ist. Das heißt, der eins ist immer die bessere Wahl, aber die Leute sehen halt die Größe der jeweiligen Mengen nicht im Vergleich, sondern nur die Wahrscheinlichkeiten für einzelne Mitglieder in den Mengen. Das ist sozusagen dasselbe in grün wie dieses Leute in Krankenhäusern-Problem. Das ist ein wohlbekanntes Problem aus den 70ern. Das ist, glaube ich, irgendwie 78 oder so. Hat eine Wikipedia-Seite so bekannt, ist das Problem. Das ist ein Effekt. Den muss man einfach mal gesehen haben, damit man den erkennt, wenn man ihn wieder vor sich hat.
Ich frage mich gerade nur so, was macht man dann jetzt als Politiker da eigentlich?
Ich glaube, wenn du als Politiker anfängst, den Leuten mit Studien was erklären zu wollen, kann das gut gehen, aber es kann auch voll nach hinten losgehen. Weil, dass du eine Studie lesen kannst, ist ja eine Kompetenz, die du dir erstmal angeeignet haben musst. Also wenn ich jetzt ein Paper aus der Physik lese, verstehe ich ja kein Wort, was nicht daran liegt, dass sie zu blöd waren, ein Paper zu schreiben, sondern ich kenne halt die ganzen Grundlagen nicht, um die es in den Paper gehen wird. Und das ist natürlich bei Medizin genauso. Das heißt, ich kann so ein bisschen überfliegen und ich kann mir, der am Anfang ist meistens eine Zusammenfassung, die so ein bisschen verständlicher formuliert ist, aber um so etwas wirklich folgen zu können, das kann man nicht allen in der Gesellschaft zumuten und rein zeitlich schon nicht. Deswegen haben wir ja die Politik, weil wir gerne möchten, dass die dann Ausschüsse gründen, die dann mit Experten besetzt sind, die diese Papers auch verstehen können. Das passiert dann leider nicht, sondern diese Ausschüsse werden dann mit irgendwelchen Partei-Buchträgern besetzt und am Ende wird paritätisch entschieden. Aber das war ja mal die Idee von den Ausschüssen. Daher wählen wir ja Vertreter, damit die die Zeit haben, sich in den Scheiß einzuarbeiten, bevor sie Entscheidungen treffen. Insofern sollten wir die Politik auch wieder in eine Position bringen, wo man ihnen vertrauen kann, weil das ist die Idee von unserem System. Das ist glaube ich das größte Problem, was wir gerade haben, dass die Leute anfangen, einfach der Politik nicht mehr zu vertrauen. Ja, völlig zu Recht. Ich ja auch nicht.
Ja, aber ich meine, letztendlich ist halt diese Frage halt irgendwie von, wenn es halt irgendwie so schwierig ist, halt den Unterschied zwischen einer Korrelation und tatsächlich dem kausalen Zusammenhang irgendwie rauszudestillieren, was ja in einer immer komplexeren Welt, wo man halt immer mehr Faktoren hat, die eine Rolle spielen können, dann wird es halt eben auch immer schwieriger, tatsächlich objektiv richtige Entscheidungen zu fällen.
Ja, also es gibt so eine schöne Webseite, die haben wir glaube ich auch schon mal bei Alternativlos verlinkt gehabt, über sogenannte spurious correlations. Da gibt es dann so irgendwie das, was war das Beispiel, mit dem die gestartet haben, war irgendwie die Entwicklung der Temperaturen und die Piraterie. Und da kam dann irgendwie so, was also offensichtlich unzusammenhangfrei ist. Aber wenn du halt tatsächlich einfach einen Computer nimmst und Kurven vergleichst, wirst du lauter Sachen finden, die aussehen, als hätten sie irgendeine Verbindung. Haben sie aber nicht. Aber der Mensch möchte gern Verbindungen sehen. Darauf ist unser Gehirn ausgelegt.
Ja, genau. Wir sind ja Korrelationsmaschinen. Das führt dann eben doch dazu, zu diesem Ding, was man eben beim Gamblen hat. Wenn halt eine Weile kein Rot kam, dann nimmt man ein, jetzt muss doch irgendwann mal Rot kommen. Obwohl jeder einzelne dieser Würfe, wenn die Roulette-Maschine gut funktioniert, in sich unabhängig ist.
Ja, also da denkt das Gehirn sich dann Korrelationen aus, wo es keine gibt. Ja, und das ist auch bei Covid. Ja, da gibt es halt auch Leute, die sagen, hey hör mal, ich laufe jetzt hier irgendwie, ich arbeite auf der Baustelle, ja, oder sowas. Also Baustelle ist jetzt sowieso irgendwie ein Reizthema. Ich habe die Tage so eine Zuschrift gekriegt von jemandem, der auf einer Baustelle arbeitet, meinte, die scheißen alle auf Corona. Also da gibt es überhaupt nichts, so keine Masken, kein gar nichts. Also, aber so die Idee wäre dann zu sagen, ich arbeite irgendwie die ganze Zeit auf der Baustelle. Und wenn, wenn es irgendwie eine Gefahr gäbe, dann hätte ich es ja schon erwischt. Und so funktioniert das halt nicht. Du hast jeden Tag, hast du wieder Risiko erwischt zu werden. Das heißt nicht, dass dein Immunsystem gut ist, sondern dass du Glück gehabt hast bisher.
Und trotzdem, das passiert halt trotzdem, dass Leute vom Platz getroffen werden.
Ja, der Schlüssel ist, dass das Experiment häufig genug durchgeführt wird. Ja, und dann passieren halt auch sehr seltene Sachen plötzlich. Ich hab vorhin schon ein bisschen vorweg gegriffen, den Confirmation-Bias, der ist so, dass entweder Platz eins oder zwei von den schlimmsten Biases, die es gibt, weil die einen komplett in die Irre führen können, ohne dass man es merkt. Also die Idee von dem Bias ist, dass wenn ich anfange, nach Dingen zu gucken, dann seh ich sie auch häufiger, als wenn ich nicht nach ihnen geguckt habe.
Einfaches Experiment dazu ist, einfaches Experiment dazu ist halt so, die Straßen liegen voller Geld. Wenn du irgendwie das häufig wieder genug wiederholst und irgendwie auf den Boden guckst, und dann die Überzeugung bist, dass die Straßen wirklich voller Geld liegen, wirst du halt einfach auch mehr 10 Cent-Stücke auf der Straße finden.
Ja, also es ist ja auch logisch. Das ist ja die Definition von nach Dingen gucken.
Genau.
Ja, dass man sie dann auch sieht, wenn sie da sind. Und die sind halt die ganze Zeit da, aber du siehst sie halt nicht normalerweise, weil das nicht relevant ist. Wenn du jetzt eine Theorie hast, die irgendeine Aussage trifft, und du möchtest die gern glauben, dann wirst du lauter Dinge finden, die die Theorie zu stützentscheiden. Und wenn du mal zwischendurch was findest, was die Theorie wiederlegen würde, dann bist du geneigt, die wegzudiskutieren. Da gibt es dann irgendwelche Gründe, warum das irgendwie ein Messfehler ist oder so. Und das ist ein Riesenproblem, ja. Weil das kann sogar dazu führen, dass du Messwerte entgegengesetzt bewertest. Also wenn du zum Beispiel als Messwert hast, bei Covid sterben so und so viel und bei Grippe und Straßenverkehr sterben vergleichbar viel, so eine ähnliche Größenordnung, sag ich mal. Wenn du jetzt ein Confirmation-Bias in die Richtung hast, wir müssen endlich mehr gegen Covid tun, dann wirst du sagen, guck mal, so viele Tote hat Covid, das ist ja furchtbar, da müssen wir jetzt mal was machen. Aber wenn du ein Confirmation-Bias in die Gegenrichtung hast, Covid ist nicht so schlimm, dann sagst du, hey, das ist ja alles irgendwie, sogar bei Grippe und Straßenverkehr, da nehmen wir so was hin. Warum so macht ihr jetzt bei Covid so ein Ding? Das heißt, wir haben hier einen Bias, der dazu führt, dass man Messwerten nicht mehr einfach vertrauen kann. Die sind jetzt nicht mehr wertfrei, sondern die Interpretation davon hängt ab, was der Beobachter sehen wollte. Und das ist halt wichtig, dass ihr das bei euch selbst beobachtet, ob ihr das gerade habt oder nicht.
Ja, genau, da gibt es natürlich auch noch eine, wenn man es dann ins Extrem treiben will, also halt so dieses, was ist, ich keine Ahnung, die Impfstoffe sind halt gechipt, in den Impfstoffen sind die bösen 5G-Chips von Bill Gates. So, dann wird man dafür im Zweifel auch irgendwelche Leute finden im Internet, die das behaupten oder irgendwelche Anzeichen finden, dass plötzlich der Telefonempfang nach der Impfung besser wurde oder was auch immer. Und da kommt man halt dann irgendwie an der Stelle zum Glück relativ einfach raus, weil man kann sich einfach angucken, was ist der tatsächliche Durchmesser der Nadeln, mit denen geimpft wird und was ist tatsächlich der kleinste funktionsfähige Mikrochip. Und dann wird man darauf kommen, dass da noch so zwei Größenordnungen dazwischen sind. Aber der Größe.
Jetzt hast du es verraten.
Ja gut, aber sowas wird natürlich dann auch für gezielte Desinformationskampagnen benutzt. Also gerade diese Chips von Bill Gates Nummer. Da bin ich mir immer nicht so ganz sicher, ob das jetzt irgendwie ein Joke war, der dann halt irgendwie durcheskaliert ist oder ob es halt irgendjemand absichtlich in die Welt gesetzt hat, mit dem Ziel, möglichst viel Dissens zu sehen.
Aber der Punkt jedenfalls bei Confirmation Bias ist, dass das war sozusagen die Waffe von QAnon. Die haben einfach gesagt, ja, google das doch selbst. Und dann bist du losgegangen und hast nach der absurden, obskuren Theorie gegoogelt und findest natürlich Seiten über die Theorie. Was denn sonst? Und Leute, die da noch nie nach gegoogelt haben, die haben gar nicht mitgekriegt, dass es diese Theorie gibt. Deswegen gab es keine Debunking. Und das ist sozusagen die Waffenversion von dem Confirmation Bias, die wirklich gut funktioniert hat. Also QAnon, da sind echt viele Leute betroffen gewesen. Das waren nicht nur so ein paar Deppen, sondern das waren richtig viele.
Also was ich da in dem Zusammenhang unterhaltsam fand, war halt der Versuch zu sagen, so mit diesem Virus, mit diesem Impfpartikel-Shedding. Also die Behauptung, dass Leute, die geimpft sind, halt Partikel von sich geben, die halt dann irgendwie ungeimpfte, quasi durch Ausatmung zwangsimpfen. Passivimpfung. Da kam dann aber tatsächlich irgendein begnadeter Troll auf die Idee zu sagen, ja und der Weg euch davor zu schützen ist, dass ihr irgendwie möglichst gute Masken tragt, damit er die nicht einatmet.
Ja, das ist alles irgendwie eine Quelle von viel Humor, aber das nützt halt den Betroffenen nichts, wenn sich andere über sie lustig machen. Ja, das stimmt. Ist die Hoffnung, dass wir jetzt hier mal die Mechanismen erklären und dann könnt ihr das hoffentlich bei euch selbst erkennen und verhindern. Ja, gerade bei Covid ist auch häufig ein Problem, dass Leuten einfach die Grundinformationen entweder fehlen oder dass sie intuitiv eine falsche Vorstellung haben, was das bedeutet. Also zum Beispiel gab es da die Rede von Langzeitnebenwirkungen. Und damit sind, das ist aber ein Begriff, das ist nicht nur, hat sich irgendwie jemand das Wort erfunden, sondern das ist ein feststehender Begriff und das heißt eine Wirkung, die lange anhalten. Das ist nicht eine Wirkung, die erst nach einem Jahr auftritt. Ja, die treten alle innerhalb von einer Woche oder zwei auf, wenn es hochkommt. Aber die bleibt dann halt lange, das macht die Langzeit. Ja, so das heißt, aber wenn du so ein Paper oder eine Studie liest und du weißt es nicht, dann denkst du irgendwie vielleicht, da gibt es Nebenwirkungen, die kommen erst nach zwei Jahren. Na dann nehme ich jetzt aber die Impfung lieber noch nicht. Ja, aber das ist halt ein Missverständnis von jemandem, der diesen Begriff nicht kannte. Das hat mit der Realität nichts zu tun. Die Nebenwirkungen, die irgendwie ein Jahr später auftreten können, sind nach Stand der Wissenschaft ausgeschlossen bei mRNA-Impfstoffen, weil das abgebaut wird, das Zeug. Das muss auch so sein, weil nämlich diese RNA-Geschichten auch im normalen Körper auftauchen und abgebaut werden müssen. Also, da gibt es existierende Mechanismen für. Das ist nicht irgendwie Hightech, sondern das macht der Körper eh, diesen Scheiß wegschmeißen. Die Furcht ist komplett unbegründet, aber das versteht man halt erst, wenn man die Begriffe verstanden hat. So ein anderes Ding, was mir jetzt immer wieder Ärger gemacht hat, sind Totimpfstoffe. Das ist ein Begriff, der passt überhaupt nicht, denn der geht um Bakterien. Bakterien haben nämlich Leben. Aber Viren leben gar nicht, die haben keinen Stoffwechsel. Das heißt, alles, selbst wenn nicht funktionierende Viren und irgendwie geschwächte Viren verabreiche, wäre das per Definition immer noch ein Totimpfstoff. Also diese ganze, das Gerede von Totimpfstoffen ist Bullshit, aber das verstehst du halt erst, wenn du weißt, was ein Totimpfstoff ist. Oder so Masken. Masken war auch so ein Ding. Gut, aber es gibt viele solche Missverständnisse. Der Punkt ist halt, nur weil ihr glaubt, etwas verstanden zu haben, heißt es nicht, ihr habt es auch verstanden. Ich würde lieber noch mal ein paar Kumpels abklären. Am besten mit Experten abklären.
Nicht nur mit Kumpels. Bei Masken muss man leider sagen, hat der Staat aber auch wirklich einfach... Und die Medien ist halt irgendwie echt grob versemmelt. Also das ist halt so dieses... Also zuerst hieß es ja, wir brauchen keine Masken, oder beziehungsweise Masken könnten schädlich sein, weil man sie falsch aufsetzt oder sich die Finger dann am Äußeren der Maske infiziert. Und es war zu einem Zeitpunkt, wo die Studienlage aus Japan halt schon so dermaßen eindeutig war, dass es halt einfach wissenschaftlicher Bullshit war. Und dann sind sie ja hin zu, ja, wir haben jetzt leider nur Scheißmasken, deswegen definieren wir jetzt die Funktion der Masken, als die Masken sollen nicht dich schützen, sondern die sollen andere vor dir selbst schützen. So und also quasi sozusagen die Wahrscheinlichkeit verringern, dass wenn du infiziert bist, du andere ansteckst. Woraus dann halt irgendwie dieser ganze Quatsch mit diesen sogenannten medizinischen Masken, also im Volksmund auch Blauläppchen genannt resultierte. Also es ist halt, da könnte ich mich endlos aufregen. Es ist halt einfach so ein dermaßenes Versagen, also da fehlen mir halt wirklich die Worte. Und klar, wenn du halt irgendwie eine Maske hast, die andere vor der Infektionsschütze ist gut, aber besser ist halt einfach auch eine Maske zu tragen, die beides Puten, nämlich halt eine ordentliche Filterwirkung hat und andere vor der Infektionsschütze. Und wenn ich schon eine Maske...
Na die kostet halt viel mehr und die Lieferbarkeit war schon bei den scheiß Masken schlecht. Das hättest du halt nicht vorschreiben können als Politik.
Nee, man hätte dafür sorgen können, dass genug am Start ist. Das war jetzt nicht unabsehbar. Also ich meine, das ist jetzt nicht so, dass ich der Einzige bin, der irgendwie als es in China losging angefangen hat, hat irgendwie einfach erst mal Masken zu kaufen, so weil halt klar war, dass das halt helfen wird.
Du warst der, der die Preise hochgetrieben hat. Ja, jetzt verstehe ich das hier.
Die Preise nicht hochgetrieben. Ich hab damals irgendwie für echt geringe Geldbeträge relativ große Mengen Masken eingekauft. Das war jetzt auch nicht schwierig. Ich hab sie halt nicht für Profit weiterverkauft, sondern verschenkt. Also das ist halt so ein klarer Fall von politische Kommunikation kann da echt viel Unheil anrichten, wenn sie halt wirklich aus politischen Gründen daneben liegt. Anstatt den Leuten zu sagen, wir haben jetzt leider nicht genug Masken, wir wollen aber, dass sie richtige Masken haben, wäre es halt die richtige Ansage gewesen. Und übrigens übernächste Woche haben wir genug Masken für alle. Wäre jetzt auch nicht so ein Problem gewesen, wenn man rechtzeitig damit angefangen hätte. Aber stattdessen machen sie jetzt halt diesen Quatsch mit medizinischen Masken. Entschuldigung, ich hab da irgendwie... Also es ist... Da fehlen mir so ein bisschen nichtjustizierbare Worte. Also, um es noch mal eine Empfehlung zu formulieren, kauft euch wenigstens FFP2-Masken, und zwar welche, die gut sitzen. Besser FFP3-Masken, die gut sitzen. Irgendwie woher man merkt, wenn ihr einatmet, dass die Maske ein kleines Stückchen zurückkommt, dann sitzt die Maske tatsächlich gut. Alles andere ist Bullshit.
Ja, gut, ich glaube, ein Teil der Scheiße sollte auch bei den Medien landen, die natürlich wie immer versucht haben, beide Seiten zu zeigen. Und dann irgendwie, ja, Masken sind total gut und wichtig. Aber wenn du sie vielleicht falsch aufsetzt, könntest du eventuell, ich glaube, so war das. So ist das jedenfalls bei mir angekommen.
Ich hab damals tatsächlich irgendwie mir Tagesschau-Webseiten-Screenshots gemacht, weil ich dachte, da werden die bestimmt irgendwann leugnen, dass das so war, dass sie gesagt haben, nee, Masken, setz mal lieber keine Masken auf. Ey, das war wirklich ein Verbrechen. Anyway.
Gut, also damit sind wir jetzt sozusagen mit der ersten Kategorie durch. Jetzt gibt es aber auch echte Betrugsabsicht oder Irreführung, sagen wir mal, ein bisschen weniger schlimm. Und das kann man auch super machen mit Statistiken. Die häufigste Version, die man sieht, sind Statistiken, bei denen auf den Achsen nicht der volle Wertebereich gezeigt wird. Das ist häufig in der Werbung oder so. Da siehst du dann halt einen möglichst kleinen Ausschnitt des Wertebereichs, damit der Unterschied zwischen der Vorversion und der neuen Version groß aussieht, weil das Werbung ist. Oder dass die Skala logarithmisch ist und sie sagen es nicht explizit an oder so Sachen. Also auf die Achse müsst ihr gucken, was sind das eigentlich für Werte, die hier geplottet werden, aber das ist ja noch relativ klar. Ein bisschen schwieriger wird es schon, wenn die anfangen, ein Merkmal darzustellen, was völlig unrelevant ist. Zum Beispiel im Moment reden immer noch alle über die Inzidenzen. Das ist eigentlich ziemlich sinnlos. Erstens, weil wir da keine ordentliche Datenbasis haben. Zweitens, weil das Reporting im Arsch ist. Und drittens, weil wir ja wissen, dass die Impfung Ansteckungen nicht 100 Prozent verhindert. Was wir eigentlich wissen wollen, ist, ob die Impfung ihren Hauptzweck erfüllt, nämlich dafür sorgen, dass die Leute nicht ins Krankenhaus müssen. Und da müssten wir so was angucken, wie zum Beispiel den Quotienten aus Hospitalisierungen pro Infektion oder so was. Aber die reinen Infektionszahlen sind weitgehend sinnlos.
Naja, finde ich nicht ganz eczendent. Sie wurden als getrennte Inzidenz nach Geimpften und Ungeimpften ausgewertet. Das wäre eine sinnvolle Statistik, weil sie unter anderem einen Hinweis darauf geben kann.
Aber das sagt dir auch nur Sachen, die du schon wusstest oder nicht?
Nein, nein, das ist nicht richtig.
Ist das noch eine Frage, dass die Impfung irgendwie...
Ja, Moment....
dass wir alle nicht impfen lassen sollten?
Nein, nein, das steht nicht in Frage. Momentan haben wir wahrscheinlich so eine 10 zu 1-Quote bei den Inzidenzen zwischen Geimpften und Ungeimpften. Aber es wird halt schlechter. Das heißt, wir sehen, dass die Wirksamkeit der Impfung nachlässt, wenn sie sechs Monate her ist oder fünf Monate her ist und man sich deswegen boostern lassen sollte. Aber diese Aussage ließe sich sehr viel reziser und sinnvoller treffen anhand einer getrennten Inzidenzstatistik von Geimpften und Ungeimpften. Und die findet man nur sehr sporadisch. Also die ist halt wirklich nur, weil halt diese Daten bisher offensichtlich nur zufällig oder teilweise systematisch erhoben werden und sich in den RKI-Statistiken immer noch nicht widerspiegeln. Naja, die kriegen jetzt schon den Rest nicht erhoben. Ja, aber das wäre tatsächlich aus meiner Sicht tatsächlich, ne? Also um halt diese Wahrscheinlichkeits-Biases halt auch ein bisschen in den Griff zu bekommen, wäre eine Aussage, also wenn du einfach jeden Tag in der Zeitung nicht irgendwie die Wir haben jetzt ein Inzidenz von 470 oder so was lesen würdest, sondern wir haben eine Inzidenz von 50 bei den Geimpften und von 1200 bei den Ungeimpften, das wäre eine Aussage, die glaube ich sehr viel mehr Leute auch einfach zum Nachdenken bringen würde, was jetzt irgendwie die eigenen Wahrscheinlichkeiten angeht. So und wieso die nicht erhoben werden, diese Statistiken, das ist halt wieder mal so ein klarer Fall von Staatsvorsatz, tut mir leid.
Ja, also es gibt auch Studien, die tatsächlich aktiv gefälscht werden oder das muss nicht, das muss nicht mit Vorsatz sein. Das passiert auch unterbewusst teilweise. Das häufigste Verfahren dafür nennt sich Cherry Picking. Nehmen wir mal an, ein Pharmaunternehmen möchte neues Produkt auf den Markt werfen und muss halt eine Zulassung beantragen und dann müssen sie die Wirksamkeit nachweisen. Und das heißt aber, sie müssen eine Studie zeigen, bei der die Wirksamkeit nachgewiesen werden konnte. Das heißt aber nicht, sie machen nur eine Studie, sondern es kann auch heißen, sie machen fünf Studien und weisen und reichen die ein, bei der am meisten Wirksamkeit zu sehen war. Das heißt aber nicht, dass das generell so gut wirkt. Ja, das wäre zum Beispiel Cherry Picking. Oder es kommt auch vor, dass einfach Studien komplett gefälscht sind. Das gab es jetzt zum Beispiel bei einer Studie aus Ägypten. Da kam dann irgendwie, da hat dann jemand sich die Werte genauer angesehen, was man übrigens der Studie anrechnen muss, dass sie die Rohdaten überhaupt zur Verfügung gestellt haben. Das ist leider nicht Standard. Sollte es sein, ist es aber noch nicht. So, und das hat diese Studie halt gemacht. Und da kam dann halt raus, dass da irgendwie Patienten mit den exakt selben Daten ein Dutzendfach vorkamen. Da war also offensichtlich irgendwie Copy und Paste bei den Patientendatensätzen gemacht worden. Die Studiendurchführer haben dann gemeint, oh, da haben wir versindlich den falschen Datensatz veröffentlicht. Kann ja mal passieren. Mag ja auch sein, aber den glaubt halt nie wieder jemand. So das Problem war, dass das eine Studie war, die sozusagen die zentrale Säule war, auf der diese Ivermectin-Glaubwürdigkeit basierte. Und als die dann zurückgezogen werden musste, dann brach halt das ganze Ivermectin-Gebäude zusammen in sich.
Aber da war es dann halt schon zu spät für die öffentliche Wahrnehmung mit den entsprechenden Zirkeln, ne?
Ja, natürlich. Aber unter Experten oder Leuten, die sich halt versucht haben, tatsächlich selber anzugucken und nicht nur irgendwie T-Online-Berichterstattung geguckt haben, ist Ivermectin natürlich durch seit dieses Studium geplatzt. Ja, außerdem, es gibt auch als Teil des wissenschaftlichen Prozesses ein aktiver Versuch, dass man Papers entlarvt als falsch, indem man sie versucht nachzustellen zum Beispiel oder indem man guckt, ob man systematische Fehler findet. Und da gibt es eine zentrale Datenbank und Whatblogs und so. Das könnt ihr alles mal googeln. Da sind auch echt viele Corona-Papers natürlich drauf, weil die im Moment den Paper-Output praktisch dominieren. Ist ja klar, wer jetzt in Medizin grad was macht, der wird wahrscheinlich um Corona sich handeln. Also das heißt jetzt nicht, dass Corona irgendwie von Betrügern besetzt ist, sondern das heißt einfach, da gucken jetzt auch viele Leute hin. Das ist sozusagen natürlich ein Teil des Prozesses, aber es kann eben sein, dass eine Studie gut aussieht und dann sich als Fraud rausstellt.
Na ja, da gibt es ja auch diesen absichtlichen Fraud durch Einschränkung der Messreihen. Also das haben wir gerade im Bereich von Klimawandel-Argumentationen sehr häufig, dass dann einzelne, also zum Beispiel, es fiel mir neulich auch beim Arktis-Meereis, also wie viel Eis bildet sich jeden Winter in der Arktis. Und da gab es halt so ein Ding, es sind so, ja, irgendwie zwischen 2015 und 2016, 2017 oder so was, ist ja tatsächlich das Volumen des Meereises halt irgendwie angestiegen, es kann noch gar nicht sein. Und wie so behaupten dann die anderen das Gegenteil. Und wenn man sich dann halt mal die gesamte Messreihe anguckt, also quasi so die letzten, keine Ahnung, 20 oder 25 Jahre, die es irgendwie sinnvolle Messwerte dafür gibt, dann sieht man halt, naja, das war halt so ein kleiner Bump in der Kurve, der halt exakt genau in diesem ausgewählten Messbereich nach oben ging. Also wo halt einfach eine zyklische Schwankung zugrunde liegt. Also die Kurve ist halt so eine Sinus-Kurve, die nach unten geht. Dann haben sich genau so einen kleinen Sinus genommen, der nach oben ging und dann nur genau den betrachtet, um halt zu sagen, ja, aber ist doch gar nicht so schlimm mit dem Ereis. So und das ist halt so eine relativ typische Vorgehensweise, die man halt insbesondere im Bereich von Klimastudien sieht, dass durchaus weil eines geschickt gewählten Datenbereichs dann halt irgendwie der globale große Trend halt verschleiert wird oder ins Gegenteil verkehrt wird.
Es gibt es auch bei Impfen, und dieses Mal sogar in die Gegenrichtung, das will ich also auch nicht verschweigen. Das finde ich auch ein Problem. Wenn im Moment die impfrate erwähnt wird, dann ist das eine Prozentangabe, die sich aber auf die Gesamtbevölkerung bezieht. So von denen können wir aber gar nicht alle impfen. Also zum Beispiel die Kinder können wir noch nicht impfen.
Also können wir schon, aber wir wollen es nicht.
Ja, also ist nicht zugelassen. Kannst du nicht legal impfen?
Na die IMA hat es schon zugelassen, also zumindest für über 5-Jährige. Aber die STIKO will halt nicht.
Ja, also das ist auch in Bewegung schon klar. Aber der Punkt ist, diese Prozentangabe bezieht sich halt nicht auf die impffähigen, sondern auf die Gesamtbevölkerung. Das heißt, die wird immer kleiner sein als der tatsächliche, was wir schon erreicht haben. Das kann man also nicht als Wert nehmen, um zu sagen, wie weit wir mit unserem Impfprogramm sind, sondern da müsste man mit den vergleichen, die man impfen kann. Und da ist unsere Quote dann auch direkt deutlich höher.
Ja, es gibt halt schon Maßzahlen, die sozusagen die impffähige Bevölkerung berücksichtigen. Aber das ist halt auch ein wesentlicher Grund dafür, warum die offiziellen Angaben über die Impfquote und die Angaben, die zum Beispiel bei umfragen rauskommen, wie viele Leute geimpft sind, so drastisch auseinanderliegen. Also wenn man diese umfragen halt nimmt, wo ja in der Regel halt Fünfjährige nicht ans Telefon gehen können, sind wir halt irgendwie bei deutlich über 80 Prozent. Und die, während wir, ich weiß nicht, was gerade die aktuelle offizielle Im-Quote ist, aber irgendwie sowas wie 78.
Aber wenn du die Leute rausnimmst, die nicht geimpft werden können, sind es eher so 90 Prozent. Denn da sind ja auch die Genesenen drin. Das sind inzwischen in Deutschland so was wie fünf Millionen. Also es ist kein unsyndifikanter irgendwie. Wenn du die alle zusammenzählst, haben wir eine Impfquote von über 90 Prozent bei den Leuten, die wir hätten impfen können oder die irgendwie anderweitig genesen kann man ja auch als geimpft zählen.
Ja, das immunisiert, ja.
Und das wäre eigentlich so, warum ich das hier erwähne, ist, weil es wird ja gern Deutschland mit Israel verglichen. Und in Israel ist die Impfquote, die die Regierung ansagt, die von den impffähigen. Ja, das heißt, dass die Impfquote da besser ist, liegt nicht daran, dass die irgendwie besser impfen, sondern die messen anders, ja. So, und da muss man halt gucken, dass es wieder Auswahl des Datensetzes kann benutzt werden, um das Ergebnis zu verfälschen. Und das passiert auch. Also, da muss man jetzt hier genau hingucken. Ja, und was wir vorhin schon erwähnt haben, das ist natürlich auch generell ein Problem bei Statistiken, dass häufig die Datenbasis unzureichend ist. Also zum Beispiel gibt es in Deutschland gar keinen impfregister. Der Staat weiß gar nicht, welche Personen geimpft sind und welche nicht, sondern das steht in deinem Impfbuch, nicht im Zentralen, in der Datenbank irgendwo. Und das heißt eben auch, dass die Statistiken nicht aus einer schönen Primärquelle Datenbank kommen, sondern die müssen aus anderen Quellen kreuzreferenziert und errechnet werden. Oder es gibt halt eine umfrage und da wundert man sich dann, dass da ganz andere Werte rauskommen, das hat Frank ja schon erzählt, gerade wie das dazu kommt. Ja, und dann gibt es natürlich noch Fragen, wo zieht man eigentlich die Linie? Also zum Beispiel, ab wann sage ich, das ist ein Toter, der an Covid gestorben ist oder der vielleicht mit Covid gestorben ist. Das haben ja auch die Impfgegner sofort darauf gesprungen. Das ist auch eine Frage. Wenn ich eine Statistik über Messwerte mache, dann müssen solche Fragen klar geklärt und auf den Tisch gelegt werden. Sonst ist die Aussage wertlos.
Das ist aber auch, glaube ich, so ein Problempunkt, halt in der Ehrlichkeit der politischen Kommunikation zu diesem Thema, dass halt einfach die, die halt unglaublich viel Vertrauen verspielt wurde, indem man halt irgendwie mit solchen manipulativen Tricks gearbeitet hat.
Gut, also weitere Sachen, die Statistik fälschen können, ist, wenn die Annahmen schon falsch sind. Zum Beispiel gibt es historisch, sind Studien eigentlich fast immer mit männlichen Probanden gemacht worden, weil man nicht riskieren wollte, dass eine Frau irgendwie vielleicht schwanger ist und ihr Kind verliert oder noch schwanger werden wollte. Und das fällt dann wegen diesem Test. Deswegen hat man eigentlich immer auch absichtlich hauptsächlich mit Männern getestet und nahm dann halt an, dass die Ergebnisse direkt auf Frauen übertragbar sind. Und das stimmt auch häufig, aber nicht immer. Oder muss nicht das Geschlecht sein. Das kann auch eine einzige Ethnie sein. Aber jetzt, das kann auch voll nach hinten losgehen. Also zum Beispiel gab es gerade eine Studie oder überhaupt, es gab so Meta-Studien, komme ich gleich noch zu Ivermectin, ob das jetzt hilft. Und da gab es diverse kleinere Studien, die gezeigt haben, dass Ivermectin einen Effekt hat. Und es stellt sich dann raus, das war alles in Gegenden, wo es einen Parasitenbefall bei Menschen gibt. Und die Primärwirkung von Ivermectin ist Parasitenbekämpfung. Das heißt, die wahrscheinlichste Erklärung dafür, dass nur diese Studien einen Effekt gezeigt haben, ist, dass die nicht gegen Covid geholfen haben. Aber wenn du eine normale Covid-Behandlung machst, wird das Immunsystem möglicherweise so geschwächt, dass die Würmer dich dann umbringen. Und das hat halt Ivermectin verhindert. Das heißt, die Annahme, auf die man so eine Statistik macht oder eine Studie, ist teilweise entscheidend darüber, ob das Ergebnis irgendwie einen Wert hat oder nicht. Und da muss man also auch genau hingucken.
Das ist dann auch genau wieder so eine Frage der Repräsentativität. Also wie gut ist halt die Studie darin, die Bevölkerung zu repräsentieren, auf die du halt dann deine Ergebnis-Aussage beziehst? Das ist ja auch irgendwie so ein, also gerade in der Medizin halt so ein beliebtes Thema. Nicht nur irgendwie männlich, weiblich, sondern auch irgendwie Altersgruppen. Und in der Politik wird es ja auch immer gerne genommen, dass man halt irgendwie die sich dann halt irgendwie umfragen bzw. herauspickt, Altersgruppen herauspickt und die dann halt irgendwie nach vorne stellt.
Ja, und häufig gelingt es halt nicht, Probanden so zu finden, dass sie die Bevölkerung richtig abbilden. Und was man dann macht, ist, dass man es rückrechnet. Also das heißt, man guckt, ich habe jetzt mal ein Interview gesehen mit einem schwarzen Jugendlichen in Deutschland und es stellt sich halt raus, dass der irgendwie aus persönlichen oder familiären Gründen die CDU total toll fand, aber er war halt in seiner Altersgruppe ein absoluter Ausreißer. So und was dann passiert ist, ist, dass der in irgendeiner umfrage drin war. Aber weil er der einzige in der Altersgruppe war, der auch schwarz war, wurde er halt durch diese Nachkorrektur und es auf die Bevölkerungsverteilung umzurechnen, damit es repräsentiv wird, hat er halt absolut überproportionales Gewicht bekommen. Das heißt, die Statistik sah dann so aus, als würden alle schwarzen Jugendlichen CDU toll finden, weil sie halt nur einen gefunden haben, der in dieser umfrage teilgenommen hat aus der Gruppe. Und das, also vielleicht mal, um das noch ein bisschen plakativer auszudrücken, wenn man jetzt zum Beispiel guckt, welche Gruppe am besten, am meisten Chancen hat, im Lotto zu gewinnen und dann findet man eine Gruppe, die aus einer Person besteht, also sagen wir mal ein einarmiger Einradfahrer oder sowas, total selten. Und der gewinnt einmal, dann sieht das halt so aus, als wenn die Gruppe 100 Prozent Gewinnchance hat, was natürlich Blödsinn ist. Aber das ist halt dieses Repräsentativitätsproblem. Ja, jetzt haben wir noch so ein paar Randgruppendinger, die möglicherweise irgendwie am Rand eine Rolle spielen. Wir können kurz durchgehen. Also es kann auch vorkommen, dass eine Studie nicht aktiv verfälscht wird, sondern passiv. Zum Beispiel ist es so, dass es halt verschiedene Prestige gibt, was man mit so einer Studie abgreifen kann. Und eine Studie machst du ja nicht und wirst dann bezahlt dafür, sondern du musst vorher Gelder akquirieren. Und das heißt, du musst vorher begründen, was du machen willst, was du als Ergebnis zeitigen möchtest. Und da werden dann halt natürlich alle Leute versuchen, möglichst geile Sachen einzureichen. Das heißt aber, dass die überraschenden Sachen deutlich mehr beliebter sind als andere. Und man kann da ein bisschen was gegen tun, aber es kommt halt immer noch vor, dass Studien nicht ordentlich gemacht werden. Und dann ist es zum Beispiel so, dass der Arzt, man hat halt zwei Gruppen, man hat irgendwie eine Gruppe, die kriegt ein Placebo und eine Gruppe, die kriegt das Normalexperiment. Und wenn der Arzt aber weiß, ob er dir gerade ein Placebo gibt oder das richtige Medikament, verhält er sich vielleicht anders. Das wäre auch so eine passive Einwirkung. Und das kann der Patient natürlich merken. Und dann hast du einen anderen Placeboeffekt. Also diese Art, das muss nicht alles irgendwie bösartig oder manipulativ sein. Das kann auch einfach so passieren. Und das ist schwierig bis unmöglich, das rauszurechnen. Der Goldstandard ist inzwischen auch das durchführende Personal, also der Arzt, der die Spritze setzt, nicht weiß, in welcher Gruppe der Patient ist. Der weiß also nicht, ob in seiner Spritze gerade irgendwie eine Saltenlösung, Placebo oder Wirkstoff ist.
So eine doppelte Studie.
Ja, aber das ist halt sehr aufwendig. Das heißt, du brauchst halt doppelt so viele Ärzte.
Häufige halt auch mal mit ethischen Problemen behaftet. Also man hat ja jetzt bei einigen Versuchen, die es jetzt gab, also Studien, die es gab, um tatsächlich wirksame Medikamente gegen Covid zu finden, gab es, also es gibt eigentlich immer ein relativ deutliches Zeichen dafür, dass es irgendwie ein interessantes Medikament ist, nämlich dann, wenn die Studie abgebrochen wird, weil in der Nicht-Placebo-Gruppe, also in der Wirkstoffgruppe, der Effekt so stark überwiegend positiv war, dass man es ethisch nicht vertreten konnte, noch weiter Leute mit dem Placebo zu versorgen. Und da gab es halt zwei oder drei Medikamente, die halt irgendwie in relativ großen Studien tatsächlich da halt diese Schwelle überschritten haben, wo die dann gesagt haben, aus ethischen Gründen führen wir diese Studie jetzt nicht mit der Placebo-Gruppe zu Ende, sondern geben ihnen das halt richtige Medikament, weil wir halt gesehen haben, dass es halt so durchschlagend überwiegend hilft.
Was dann aber auch von den Impfgegnern als Argument benutzt wird. Die sagen dann, ja, aber jetzt wissen wir ja gar nicht, ob das irgendwelche Langzeitfolgen gehabt hat, weil wir haben ja jetzt gar keine ungeübte Gruppe mehr.
Ja gut, okay, aber das ist dann deren Problem.
Also du kannst alles immer irgendwie auslegen, als wenn der böse Kabal versucht, hier die Welt kaputt zu machen.
Logisch.
Ja. Dann gibt es noch B-Hacking. Das ist ein bisschen umfangreicher zu erklären. Das werde ich jetzt hier nur ganz kurz machen. Also wenn du ein Paper über irgendwas schreiben willst, gibt es Mindestanforderungen, wie signifikant das Ergebnis sein kann und sein muss und die Signifikanz kann man messen oder errechnen. Und die Methode dafür heißt, man rechnet ein P-Value aus. Und das heißt, wenn du praktisch eine Studie durchführst und die Signifikanz, die du ausrechnest, reicht nicht an den Mindestwert ran, dann kannst du die halt nicht publizieren, was halt dazu führt, dass die Leute dann weiterwursteln und irgendwie noch einen Probanden reinnehmen, bis die Signifikanz erreicht ist. Oder was auch sein kann, dass die Leute rausnehmen aus der Studie. Ja, dass sie sagen, okay, dann tun wir halt so, als hätten wir den Typ hier gar nicht in der Studie gehabt, weil der ist ein Ausreißer und ohne den sieht die Signifikanz viel besser aus. Also das nennt man P-Hacking. Ja, wenn praktisch der Prozess dazu führt, dass es immer so aussieht, als gäbe es eine Signifikanz, auch wenn die gar nicht da war.
Das kann man gelegentlich daran erkennen, dass es halt eine relativ hohe Menge an von den initialen Probanden relativ wenige, anteilsmäßig wenige, die am Abschluss der Studie noch dabei waren. Dann ist es halt immer ein deutliches Zeichen dafür, dass möglicherweise da jemand dieses P-Hacking betrieben hat.
Und der Goldstandard ist, wenn die Leute sich vorher auf die Probanden festlegen. Wenn du also praktisch schon beim Einreichen sagst, welche Probanden du haben willst. In der Medizin so, dass man gar nicht genug Probanden findet, um eine solide Aussage treffen zu können. Und was man dann macht, ist, man rechnet halt Studien von vielen Leuten zusammen. Ja, dann hast du halt nicht irgendwie eine Studie mit 10.000 Patienten, sondern du hast irgendwie 100 Studien mit jeweils 100. Insgesamt kommst du halt auf eine gewisse Signifikanz. Aber die Studien sind alle von verschiedenen Leuten durchgeführt worden. Und du versuchst es dann irgendwie zusammenzurechnen. Und da gibt es halt auch verschiedene Probleme, die da passieren können. So eins der offensichtlichsten ist, ist, dass man eine große und 20 kleine Studien zusammenrechnet. Und dann hat die große Studie eine Signifikanz, aber die kleinen haben alle keine Wirkung. Und dann überwiegt aber, weil in der großen Studie mehr Leute drin waren, deren Ergebnis die kleinen. Ja, so was passiert also zum Beispiel regelmäßig bei Mediastudien, das ist auch nicht unbedingt schlecht. Aber in diesem Fall war es halt so, dass die große Studie sich dann als Betrug rausstellte. Das war diese Copy-Paste-Studie aus Ägypten. Und die hatte dazu geführt, dass die Metastudien so ausseilen, als hätte die Iwamekte einen Effekt, hat es aber gar nicht gehabt. Also es gibt immer noch Studien, die einen Effekt zeigen, aber die sind dann halt aus Parasitengehenden. Aber das sind so die Effekte, die passieren können. Selbst da sieht die Studie eigentlich gut aus, die Metastudie und kann trotzdem falsche Ergebnisse bringen. Gut und zuletzt haben wir hier noch den Publication-Bias. Das gibt es erstens für Papers und zweitens aber auch für normale Medien. Es stellt sich nämlich raus, Zeitungen berichten ungern über langweiligen Scheiß, die berichten lieber über Katastrophen und überraschenden Scheiß. Bei Papers ist das ähnlich. Wenn du ein prestigeträchtiges Paper machen willst, dann musst du eine Überraschung haben. Daher bleiben viele Sachen liegen, weil die nicht überraschend sind. Die wichtigste Sache, die liegen bleibt, sind irgendwelche Replizierungen. Häufig ist die Idee, in der Medizin jemand findet etwas raus, macht ein Paper und dann versuchen andere das nachzustellen. Wenn die zum selben Ergebnis kommen, dann sagen die, die ist okay, Ergebnis validiert. Aber das ist halt unsexy. Daher wird das viel zu selten gemacht. Das ist halt ein Problem.
Tatsächlich wird es dann halt hoffentlich nur dann publiziert oder hat eine entsprechende hohe Zitierhaftigkeit, wenn sie dann die ursprüngliche Studie widerlegen konnten.
Das ist natürlich dann doch sexy, wenn du zeigen kannst, das war Bullshit.
Aber dann musst du halt irgendwie schon...
Aber das weißt du halt vorher nicht.
Da musst du dann halt schon eine gute Intuition haben, dass es irgendwie wahrscheinlich ist, um dir halt die Arbeit zu machen.
Ja. Ja, und in den Nachrichten gibt es das auch. Und das ist mir persönlich sehr wichtig, weil das die öffentliche Meinung komplett kaputt machen kann. Also zum Beispiel ist es so, dass wir seit den 1980er Jahren ein stetig fallendes Kriminalitätsniveau hatten. Und zwar weltweit, nicht nur in Deutschland.
Also seit dem Ende der Verbleibung von Autobenzin und dem Verbot von Bleifarben, muss man dazu sagen.
Ja, das ist die eine Theorie, warum das so ist. Die andere Theorie ist, dass so die Zeit war, als in den Ghettos in Amerika die Verhütungsmittel und die Abtreibungen zugänglich waren für auch die Armen. Ja, so. Und das ist völlig überraschend, wenn irgendwie die Mutter gar nicht in der Lage ist, das Kind richtig groß zu ziehen, schon finanziell nicht, dann ist es wahrscheinlich ja, dass dann ein Krimineller draus wird. Also jedenfalls die tatsächliche Verbrechtsrate ist seit ewigen Zeiten am stetigen Fallen.
Na ja, und natürlich hat man halt eben diesen Effekt der Internationalität, dass halt irgendwie besonders schwere oder grausame Verbrechen werden halt international berichtet, obwohl sie eigentlich überhaupt nichts mit deinem eigenen soziokulturellen Kontext zu tun haben.
Okay, ja, also ein Grum und Glück in Peru wäre zum Beispiel so ein Beispiel. Das hört man dann auch hier in den Nachrichten, obwohl das ja eigentlich niemand betrifft hier.
Ja, die Frage ist ja letzten Endes dann halt, wie funktioniert denn halt eigentlich wissenschaftlicher Erkenntnisgewinn noch und wie funktioniert denn die Auswahl der Datenbasis für wissenschaftliche Erkenntnis? Und unter normalen Bedingungen ist es ja so, dass die Wissenschaft der Zeit braucht. Also dass halt Studien repliziert werden, was natürlich dann irgendwie auch ein Problem ist, wenn halt irgendwie die Rohdaten nicht da sind oder es halt irgendwie sich niemand die Mühe macht, halt die Replikation zu machen. Aber so über die Zeit mittelt sich dann halt irgendwie, sagen wir mal so, die falschen Korrelationen mitteln sich raus. Man hat neue Erkenntnisse, man weiß halt, wie Korrelationsmechanismen, also wie Mechanismen funktionieren, die Kausalität implizieren. Also dass es halt eine plausible Erklärung für einen Effekt gibt. Und wir haben jetzt aber nur gerade halt in diesen Corona-Zeiten das Problem, dass die Zeit halt nicht da ist. Also dass halt einfach der Zeitdruck eben durch irgendwie die Exponentialfunktion des Infektionsgeschehens, wenn es dann einmal am Laufen ist, halt so groß ist, dass halt irgendwie die Politik halt irgendwie gerade in so einer Situation ist, wo sie halt eigentlich im Wesentlichen nur blind um sich schlagen kann und halt die zwei, drei Sachen, wo man halt weiß, dass sie funktionieren, versuchen kann zu pushen. Und so für einen selber ist halt eigentlich relativ klar, die, sag mal so, die Flussfolgerung ist halt irgendwie impfen und boostern und irgendwie ordentliche Masken tragen und infektionsgeneigte Situationen, also sprich in Innenräumen mit vielen Menschen halt irgendwie vermeiden, wenn es gerade irgendwie da draußen wieder mal brennt. Aber letzten Endes ist halt die sozusagen die nächste Krise, nämlich halt quasi die Klimakrise, wird halt dieses Problem nochmal verschärfen, weil auch da haben wir jetzt nur lange genug gepennt, dass sich jetzt halt so ein Zeitdruck einstellt und halt der Versuch halt, egal, irgendwie was zu machen, hauptsächlich sieht einigermaßen gut aus und irgendwie fühlt sich richtig an. Auch wenn sich dann hinterher herausstellt, dass es möglicherweise paradoxe Effekte gegeben hat oder dass es halt irgendwie gar nicht geholfen hat, ist halt natürlich groß. Das heißt, wir bewegen uns da halt auf so eine Zeit zu, wo halt dieses politische Entscheidungen und der Zeitdruck auf der Basis unklarer Wissenschaft, also insbesondere was jetzt irgendwie Maßnahmen, die helfen, angeht, wird halt immer mehr zunehmen so und ist halt natürlich gerade für so eine Demokratie halt irgendwie ein ziemliches Dilemma.
Ja, achtet mal auf eure Biases an der Stelle. Ja, falt nicht auf Sachen rein, bei denen irgendwie rauskommt, dass ihr euer Verhalten nicht ändern müsst. Aber da seid ihr halt vom Gehirn und der Evolution darauf vorbereitet, dass ihr so was dann eher glauben wollt, weil das halt in euer Leben besser reinpasst. Aber verarscht euch da nicht selbst.
Ja, dann bleibt uns eigentlich im Wesentlichen nur noch irgendwie euch zu wünschen, dass ihr gesund bleibt. Wir versuchen, ob wir das mit der sendungsfrequenz ein bisschen nach oben bekommen. Wir haben schon tatsächlich ein paar Sendungen geplant, aber jetzt wird es natürlich wieder etwas schwieriger, Sendungen mit Gästen zu organisieren. Mal gucken, ob wir das irgendwie auf die Reihe bekommen.
Sonst müssten wir halt weiter hier über Internet irgendwie rumpfuschen. Ich möchte noch mal um Verzeihung für die technischen Probleme, die wir haben, aber geht halt nicht anders.
Mit wenig überlegener Internettechnologie und schlechten Netzwerken in Deutschland. Ja, dann wünschen wir euch also ein gutes, gesund bleiben und danke fürs Zuhören. Falls ihr Bock habt, könnt ihr noch auf den Patronen Button da klicken. Ansonsten wünschen wir euch dann ein gutes Weihnachten oder so. Vielleicht schaffen wir vorher noch eine Sendung mal gucken.
Haha, ja, guck mich nicht so an. Na gut, dann wir tun, was wir können. Der Techniker ist informiert.
Genau. Alles klar. Bis zum nächsten Mal.